the time being 9 30 i'm about to open
the work for public works and highways
committee for today
i would remind members of
the committee that
you have to press the button make sure
the microphone is showing red because
this is live streamed and the only way
that people can hear what you are saying
or asking is if you do that
um
i will now call
house order and
um
open the
continued hearing on house bill
an act establishing a road usage
registration fee
and making an appropriation there for
the reason that it was continued is that
the prime sponsor was dealing with the
sick relative the day of the hearing and
i did he did ask that if he could come
back and explain his rationale
and i was willing to do that
so
with that i would recognize the prime
sponsor representative some serious on
house bill 1656.
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your consideration
mr chairman and
members of this committee
i have handed out an oral
presentation to you but i'm going to go
through this
the intent of this bill
is
isn't my way of thinking about it is
this
all of you know better than i
what the needs are for additional
revenue to maintain new hampshire's
roadways and bridges
you also know that the world of
transportation is changing
and that we have already seen that
impact when it comes to the declining
gasoline diesel tax revenues
however our state
only has three primary sources to fix
and maintain our roads and bridges
fueled tax revenues revenues from our
toll booths and registration
vehicle registration fees
studies including the 2020 cambridge
systems report have documented a
continuing decline in our fuel tax
revenues due to more gas efficient
vehicle standards for both cars and
trucks
and more hybrid vehicles on our roadways
the new generation of hybrids evs and
even new hydrogen fuel cell vehicles
already operating on the roadways of
california
will also impact our state at some time
at some point
there are no good political options to
raise revenues without some groups
objecting
however it is the responsibility of this
policy committee to plan for the future
of our state's infrastructure needs
i acknowledge the tough tasks you are
facing and i support hb 1040 sponsored
by representative norm majors calling
for a commission to look at new
hampshire's future needs and revenues as
the result of the coming transportation
revolution
my bill hb
1656 however provides a shorter term
solution to our declining revenues
the bill modifies the current state
vehicle registration fee based on weight
to a fee based on weight and the annual
miles miles driven
it is designed to address three primary
issues
first
since the weight-based fee has not
changed for almost 15 years
that fee is adjusted for the past 15
years of inflation loss
it creates five vehicle
weight classes instead of the current
three classes
and adjusts the classes so that lighter
vehicles pay less proportionately than
the average
while heavier vehicles pay
proportionally more
in addition it creates a new road usage
and registration fee
replacing the current weight-based oney
fee
by now adding the annual vehicle miles
traveled
vmt to the calculation of the road usage
registration fee
regardless of the fuel source of a
vehicle whether it's an ev a hydrogen or
a hybrid
if it weighs something it pays something
second it addresses a current situation
of annually declining fuel tax revenues
since the core weight-based fee in this
bill automatically is adjusted to
increase by 2.4 percent per year
this is the
recent 10-year average of increasing
national
vehicle fuel efficiency
it will compensate us annually for the
lost fuel tax revenues
and third
it should be of concern to all of us
that when our state makes promises to
residents and communities
that these promises are kept
however there are currently 49 locations
that are qualified to receive and have
been promised sound barriers against
local traffic noise
but for which no funding exists to keep
those promises
this bill would set aside five percent
of regis total registration fees
enough for one to two sites per year
for that very purpose
those locations are in the following
communities
manchester nashua dover lebanon
rochester portsmouth bedford northfield
lincoln exeter raymond seabrook warner
concord
auburn greenland hooksett
hopkinton bow and hampton falls
please keep in mind that this bill only
changes the state portion of the vehicle
registration and not the municipal
portion
for example in my personal case
when my vehicle was brand new five years
ago i paid five hundred dollar
musical fee
and only forty three dollars eight
percent of the total to the state
five years later i am now paying a 154
dollars to my municipality and again
still 43 dollars to the state which is
now a higher percentage of the total
two years ago i proposed a similar bill
what was told by members of this
committee that too many changes were
being made in one step
so this bill today has a two-step
process
in the first year the weight-based fees
are changed and for the calculation it
is assumed that everyone will have
a vehicle model traveled amount of
twelve thousand miles
however in the second year of
implementation the vehicle miles
traveled value will be collected as part
of the annual safety inspection process
and the difference between the first and
the second year odometer readings will
be assumed to be the vehicle miles
traveled of that vehicle
this can be illustrated by the following
equations
and
despite what you've heard these
calculations are not very complicated
so in the first year we have a new total
fee of the the registration use usage
and registration fee
you have a new weight-based fee
and that is multiplied
by one plus a portion for the vehicle
miles traveled
and that is
normalized to 12 000 miles and divide it
by one fourth
by four
so for example
uh in the first year with everyone
getting twelve thousand miles of vehicle
miles traveled
that would be one plus
a fourth
or 1.25 multiplied by the weight fee
so a 25
increase over the weight fee alone
in the second year
the same calculation applies but this
time we do not assume a
miles traveled number everyone will be
putting in a number that is typical or
it has been recorded for their vehicle
so for example for someone that travels
24 000 miles
that factor of 1.5 multiplied by the
weight fee
while someone that only travels
6 000 miles will multiply that new
weight fee by
a factor of 1.13
now the estimated revenues for
that will be generated by this new uh
road usage registration fee
in the first year are estimated to be
108 million dollars which would be an
increase of 36 million dollars
and in the second year
uh the the road usage registration fee
would generate between and ten thousand
million and 128 million
or an increase of between thirty eight
million and fifty six million and this
is based on the
2019 vehicle registration numbers i
haven't gotten any more recent ones
maybe someone from the department of
safety is going to be here to tell us
about that
but i'm assuming that number might be
higher by a couple percentage points
as of 2019 a vehicle total registration
fees were 72 million
as a comparison
so that's my presentation but i've also
provided you a spreadsheet
actually two spreadsheets one for the
first year and one for the second year
of this bill
and
i'm not going to go through it in detail
you can take a look at it yourself but
the
the first year
at the very bottom section it says
vehicle plus miles traveled in first
year
the first section at the very top just
shows the current situation as it is
right now
the middle part shows you what happens
when you just increase the
you make the weight change as i
suggested and the bottom part shows you
what happens when you combine the weight
changes plus the miles traveled
and you can see the the total numbers
and the additional revenue that's
generated
in in the second year um
it is because it's a little more
complicated because we don't know how
many miles people will be traveling
while he is while i'm assuming in the
first year 12 000 for everyone in the
second year i've given the scenario for
three different choices
traveling 12 000 miles traveling 24 000
miles and 7 500
and you can see what the different
revenues that are generated based on
that scenario are
but as i mentioned the additional
additional new revenue
would be something somewhere between 38
million to 46 million dollars additional
revenue
and as i said before about this bill
that every year
the weight-based number will go up by
2.4 percent uh to compensate for losses
we might be suffering uh due to
declining fuel taxes
so thank you very much mr chairman and
members and i'm glad to answer any
questions
representative
thank you thank you for taking my
question representative sampson nice to
see you in a different committee for
both of us
one of the jobs i had in the electric
and gas industry was selling contracts
to businesses
in massachusetts and connecticut and
throughout new england which
took me out of state i said mileage but
only a fraction was in new hampshire i
don't see anything in your bill
about any affidavit process so i could
claim how much was actually in new
hampshire so it gets stuck for paying
fees and all that out of state driving
as well is there any way to fix that
was there a question there
is there a way to fix that
thank you representative platt and nice
to see you here in the different
committee as well
thank you for the question and it's a
very good question however um
as you might imagine since i was here
two years ago and people thought doing
everything all at once was too
complicated
that doing something like that would be
even more complicated to actually have
verification process i tried to make it
simple we already collect the odometer
readings from the safety inspection so
that's nothing new the only thing that
happens is that those numbers not being
used for any purpose right now and this
could be used make use of that those
numbers that are already being gathered
and so
yes you could do more than
than i'm doing and have a certification
process or something it would be very
complicated i think and we've heard prop
proposals to put put tracking devices in
your car
so you could track how many miles you
are where with a gps you could do all
those things i'm trying to keep it less
complicated thank you
representative philadelphia
thank you
thank you for taking my question
thank you for taking
my question
the problem i have with this bill and
previous bills we've looked at
is the real damage to our roads are from
heavy trucks
i don't know of a single 3 000 pound car
that's ever put a crack in the hot top
uh is there going to be a question here
are we debating with the
how are we going to deal with
if we raise the
the taxes on the commercial vehicles
they'll just go to maine and register in
maine how how do we
how we got they're doing they're doing
that now
if we're going to raise it again we're
going to lose more revenue
going to maine
they'll set up an office and
any way to deal with that any ideas i
don't
well thank you representative for your
question and it's a good question and i
can't say i have an answer to that in
fact i think last week you had testimony
both from the
from jason stock from the timberland
association as well as the general
contractors
who told you that our roadways are
designed
to be used by trucks that's what they're
designed to do
and the rest of us who don't really put
much of a wear and tear on the roadways
we're just subsidizing that
and they were very resistant to any
increases in their expenses
but i would just point out that business
for-profit businesses can deduct all
these costs from their taxes you and i
as residents cannot
so i think they should step up to the
plate and say you know we we need to
contribute as well to maintaining the
roadways because we need them and we we
need these businesses too i recognize
that as well i don't know how we can do
that uh right now uh
like you've heard yet last week even the
fact that they might be increasing some
of their fees here uh
bumps up against a lot of resistance but
i agree with you that trucks are the
ones that do do the most damage and the
roadways are designed for them
thank you
representative ortiz
thank you mr chairman um so my major
concern with this is
we are just going to do this to new
hampshire residents i'm up in the lakes
region tourism is huge up there tons of
out of state traffic so why are we just
going to charge
fees to our residents when we have a
high tourist occupation up there
and i just don't think it's fair to
our residents so how can we fix that
issue
well thank you thank you representative
for the question uh
i noticed that this bill brings out all
the issues that we haven't dealt with in
the past including that one uh you know
and i i i it's it's a little bit of the
resistance that we don't like taxes we
don't like fees in this state
and it's hard to apply them to just one
group and not the other
i would say that the the most obvious
thing is raising the tolls because most
of those visitors come through the toll
booth you know that would be my
first thought
unless we
have some kind of tourist fee or
something you know if new hampshire
residents have to pay taxes for a view
why shouldn't outsiders pay some extra
fees for getting an ice for you when
they come up here
see no further questions thank you for
your testimony
that was the only pink card i had on
house bill
1656 is there anybody present
who
uh wishes to testify
anybody who has spoken once wish to
speak uh speak a second time seeing none
the public hearing on house bill
1656 is closed
we have a little bit of time before our
full work
full committee work session on the
10-year highway plan i'd like to exec a
couple of bills
full house i think everybody figured
that
the first one i'd like to bring up for
executive session
is
house bill
1432 an act prohibiting the use of state
funds for new passenger rail projects
representative blasic
uh yes i'd like to move out to pass
representative blazik moves out to pass
is there a second
representative aboard his second seat
there any discussion on the motion of
ought to pass on house bill 1432.
representative clutier
thank you mr chairman can everybody hear
me
i got the red button on i am going to
oppose this bill i'm going to vote no on
the motion of ought to pass i think this
bill is frankly premature we are still
doing the corridor study
i am concerned that if we signed a
contract this could pose some legal
problems and could be taken to court and
ruled unconstitutional either by the
state or the federal constitutions
another thing
i think it is premature
is because we're gonna we should do the
study
find out what the costs are
and then
i i don't know if state government
is
i know their concerns about state
government actually subsidizing this
line realistically
i don't i think the the best course is
probably going to be
a public private partnership with with
the state government and or the
municipalities along the
rail line and maybe some federal aid
doing this rail i don't think state
government directly
based on the fact that we can't use
highway funds that's unconstitutional
and plus general funds the general fund
is very tight as i've been talking with
people from finance and ways and means
but
i am concerned that if we pass this bill
we are going to prohibit our state dot
from helping the municipalities who want
this line in the southern part of the
state
and i've been told and by the way i was
there was a bill
i believe this committee passed and was
legislate in 2016 a public private
partnership law
that i was a co-sponsor a bipartisan
bill
and i spoke to the prime sponsor former
senator betty lafsky last night and she
said if this bill passes the way it's
written she is concerned that the state
d.o.t could not even help
the communities involved in any
public-private partnership see we were
handcuffing our own state d.o.t with all
due respect to the sponsors of this bill
and if the communities in the southern
part of the state want this
i think you know if they're willing to
pony up the money manchester nashua and
the business community which wants it
that we've heard testimony then why
should we use past this bill to handcuff
the public-private partnership thank you
very much mr chairman members of the
committee
representative
query uh thank you chairman um
it's
off i will i will also say that i am
going to oppose this motion um
it's always been something that we talk
about here in this committee is that we
never tie the hands of the future
members of this committee
and i believe that this bill does just
that and you know i i think that we
shouldn't tie the hands of future
members
thank you representative eaton
thank you mr chair i'll oppose it just
because of silliness
one legislative body cannot obligate a
future legislative body and if you
haven't been here for any amount of time
you can pass this right now and before
the session is out an amendment can get
tagged onto any bill
that says the exact opposite whatever
passes last wins
and
if you don't like the language of the
spill you can either repeal it the next
session or write another piece of
legislation that says notwithstanding
rsa such and such all you're doing is
cluttering a law book for no legitimate
purpose because any legislative body is
going to make their own decision at the
appropriate time this is feel good waste
of time silliness
thank you representative faulkner
i guess i was going to use the same
adjective but my concern is that we look
dumb
if we go ahead and decide how this
should turn out
without having the information that's
being prepared for us at the present
time
you know if we were
to you know to get this information to
decide this is too expensive we
shouldn't do it that's that's one thing
but we're
we're making a decision without the
information
and in fact it appears that we don't
want to hear the information or perhaps
we're even
afraid that the information is not going
to support the position that we might
want to take and i think that that just
uh is
it encourages disrespect of this process
of this committee and of the legislature
and i think for that reason i'm going to
oppose it
representative newman
yes thank you representative um faulkner
took stole most of my thunder i just
want to
additionally comment that some of you
who are on this committee
over a few turn a couple of terms ago
will remember one of our colleagues
she wasn't necessarily supportive of it
but she wanted to get the questions
answered and she strongly felt we owe it
to we owe it to each other we owe it to
the state to get the questions answered
as to how much this will cost and then
you make your decision thank you
thank you any further discussion
i will say one thing i did talk to the
department the way this is written it
does not impact on the ongoing study we
will still get that
that said
are you ready for the question
mr chairman one more thing
representative
everybody hear me all right okay again
i've also heard from my own local area
the city of claremont and we
host a stop in claremont that's the
vermonter the state of vermont basically
pays for the rail line but there is one
stop in new hampshire and that is in
claremont
and people in claremont are concerned
they they like rail too and they are so
concerned about the impact this bill if
they surpass
if if th that line ever needed state
help in the future
it could bar that it could also borrow
the downeaster so there's it's not just
a capital corridor project
we are going to be hindering
rail lines that we have now in this
state serving our constituents who get
on them and ride them
and i i just feel this
bill i i understand the sponsor's
intentions but i just it's got a lot of
ramifications for various reasons that
have already been spoken about thank you
mr chairman
thank you any further discussion
are you ready for the question
thank you the clerk will call the roll
thank you mr chair
representative folsom
yes
the clerk votes
yes representative sumero
representative fedolphi
yes
representative knotter
representative blasic
i could hear you
representative boards
yes
representative kaczynski yes
representative plett
yes
representative thompson
representative boyd
boyd votes high
representative clutier uh representative
claudia votes no
representative edgar
representative ebel
uh no
representative jack no
representative abbott
no
representative faulkner
representative newman
no
representative eaton
representative peterson
no
representative query
representative bunker is not here
representative
graham
yes
the vote is 11
to 11.
the motion of ought to pass fails
the
bill is without recommendation
i would expect that there will be two
reports from the committee
uh one in support of ought to pass which
will be the first vote on the floor
of the house
and one of
the expedient to legislate i assume
representative clutier yes i am okay
okay thank you
all right moving on
to
um the exact session on house bill 1432
is closed i'd like to open the executive
session
on house bill 1040.
and act establish a commission to study
revenue alternatives to the road toll
for electric and hybrid vehicles for the
funding of improvements to the state's
highways and bridges
um
representative faulkner
i'd like to
move out to pass and i have an amendment
that i'd like to offer after that
representative faulkner moves out to
pass is there a second
representative abbott moves
uh seconds the the motion it is open to
amendment representative faulkner you
said you had an amendment if you could
pass that out to everyone
representative faulkner
thank you mr mr chairman um
the amendment i'm proposing
uh representative faulkner one moment
you need to
um
formally introduce amendment
2022-02
so move we adopt amendment
2022-0205-h
thank you you may speak to your motion
the amendment does two things uh i i was
concerned that
the
focus on the title and the purpose on
electric vehicles was going to raise
opposition that we don't really need
and therefore
proposing to eliminate that particular
phrase from the first from the title in
the first section
and and where it's repeated down below
so that
you'll notice that the
[Music]
new section is titled commission to
study revenue alternatives to the road
toll
all of
the things that were in the original
bill and the sponsors
version as as introduced are still in
here
but in addition we added one additional
item that they
may consider which is to evaluate the
future funding needs
the operation and maintenance of the
highway system that's under
paragraph four f
so with those two changes i did review
this with the
representative major the sponsor he's
fine with it
i
don't think it changes the meaning
other than
you know focusing on the general problem
of revenue and of the equity of
who pays what
instead of instead of focusing on
electric vehicles
i think this improves the chances this
would pass and
i would urge everybody to support this
amendment
thank you
um
thank you just so that that i understand
the amendment you would
in this case you would also expect them
to look at things like hydrogen-powered
vehicles and how they would pay in in
that kind of
situation
yes so the
the equity of who pays what is still
listed that was one of the original
purposes and that's still in there that
hasn't been changed
any comments or questions
on the amendment
scene none all those in favor of the
adoption of amendment 2022-02058
signify by saying aye aye
opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
what is the will
having adopted the amendment what is the
will of the committee
mr church you have to
amendments no
this one we will
representative faulkner moves out to
pass as amended as
uh representative abbott
seconds
any further discussion on the bill as
amended
saying none clerk will call the roll
yes
mike okay thank you
the clerk votes yes
representative camaro yes
representative phidolphy
yes
representative notter yes
representative blasic
no
representative boards no
representative kaczynski
yes
representative plett
representative thompson
yes
representative boyd
boyd votes hi
representative claudia
representative edgar
representative evil
representative jack
i'm sorry
there we are yes
representative abbott yes
representative faulkner
yes
representative newman yes
representative eaton aye
representative peterson yes
representative querrey
yes
representative bunker is not here
representative graham
yes
mr chair the motion passes 20 to 2.
for those who voted no is there
objection to the consent calendar
anybody else
it will go on the consent calendar thank
you
i closed the executive session on house
bill 1040 and opened the executive
session on house bill 1656
which we just heard
and act establishing a road usage
registration fee and making an
appropriation thereof
what is the pleasure of the committee
representative mills whose itl
i'll second that representative mills vo
uh moved itl
on house bill 1656
uh seconded by representative borders is
there any discussion from representative
clutier
sorry can everybody hear me now
all right thank you i have a question
about the the legality or
constitutionality of some parts of this
bill i know representation just wants to
do something about the sound barriers
but i believe some of them are on
turnpikes like i think
one of the ones in portsmouth some are
on on highways and i question whether
this bill
the way it's written now would only
benefit the highway fund but then we'd
be using
money raised to maybe deal some with you
know work on sound barriers that are on
our our
that are turnpikes
and in other words we take money raised
for the highway fund and spend it on
sound barriers along turnpikes and i'm
wondering if that's legal and i don't
know if anyone and i i don't know if it
was addressed already someone from d.o.t
or somebody here to maybe
question the legality even the
constitutionality of that section of the
bill
uh representative clutter i think that
that is a great question for us to
pursue at some time maybe during the
work session on 10 40 and how things are
funded
but with the motion being inexpedient to
legislate it really does not
impact on
whether it is or not if it was not to
pass it would probably be a very
pertinent question but i think we do
need to pursue it at some point
thank you representative faulkner
thank you mr john i'm
i'm going to be sporting itl but for a
little bit different reason i
think to be consistent
we just approved this uh
commission to study the road fee
i think there are a lot of good ideas
here obviously some things need to be
worked out but i think we need to work
them out through this commission and
therefore
we should not proceed with this
particular solution at this time thank
you representative flett yes thank you
mr chair
um
representative sampson's on the same
committee as me so i'm a little careful
um i would just say i like the intent of
the bill but it's premature there's some
questions asked that couldn't be
answered such as driving out of state
and being hit with the tax or people
driving in-state from out-of-state not
getting hit with attacks
and
trucks re-registering in another state
to avoid it all sorts of questions like
that we just passed 10 40 let's do some
of the homework before we bring up
something like this again thanks
thank you any further discussion
on the motion of inexpedient to
legislate
none the clerk will call the roll
thank you mr chair
representative folsom yes
the clerk votes yes
representative samara yes
representative phadolfi yes
representative knotter yes
representative blasic
yes representative boards yes
representative kaczynski yes
representative plett yes representative
thompson yes representative boyd boyd
votes eye representative clutier uh yes
representative edgar aye
representative ebel aye
representative jack yes
representative abbott
yes
representative faulkner yes
representative newman
yes
representative eaton aye
representative peterson yes
representative query
yes
chairman graham yes
mr chairman the motion passes 22-0
the motion the vote being 22-0 the
motion of inexpedient to legislate is
any objection to the consent calendar
seeing none i will close it will go on
the
consent calendar
and
i will close the executive session on
house bill 1656.
i will now open
the executive session on house bill 1585
uh and act relatively removing the ramp
tolls at exit 11 and hooksett
what is the will of the committee
representative mills
mr chair i remove
i move itl on
house bill 1585. uh i will second motion
mr chairman lots of seconds
representative mills moves
um
expedia legislated on house bill 1585
seconded by representative clutier
is there any discussion
say none the clerk will call the roll
in just a second
on the motion itl
representative folsom yes
the clerk votes yes
representative sumero yes
representative phadolfy yes
representative knotter yes
representative blasic
yes
representative boards yes representative
kaczynski
yes
representative plett yes
representative thompson
yes
representative boyd
boyd bowtie representative clutier
yes
representative edgar aye
representative ebel aye
representative jack
i'm i'm locked out
yes
representative abbott
representative faulkner yes
representative newman yes
representative eaton aye
representative peterson yes
representative quarry
yes
chairman graham
mr chairman the vote on itl passes 22-0
the vote being 22-0 the motion of any
expedient to legislate on house bill
is adopted
is there any objection to the consent
calendar scene none it will go on the
consent calendar and i will close the
executive
session on house bill 1585
at this time i'll open the executive
session on house bill
establishing a surcharge collected
through easy pass for electric vehicles
as an alternative to the road toll
mr chairman
representative thompson
yeah i'm the sponsor of this bill and
given the testimony that was given the
other day
i'd like to propose we itl
representative thompson
uh moves in expedient to legislate on
house bill 1675 as that motion seconded
by representative abbott seconds it
is there any discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on house bill
1675.
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
thank you mr chair
representative folsom hi
the clerk votes yes
representative semero yes
representative philadelphia yes
representative notter yes
representative blasic
yes
representative boards yes
representative kaczynski
yes
representative plett yes
representative thompson yes
representative boyd
boyd votes eye
representative cloudier yes
representative edgar
representative evil
yes
representative jack yes
representative abbott
yes
representative faulkner
representative newman
representative eaton hi
representative peterson yes
representative query
yes
so bunker is not here chairman graham
mr chairman the vote itl is 22-0
the vote being 22-0 on house of
inexpedient to legislate on house bill
the motion is adopted
is there any objection to consent
saying now that will go on the consent i
will close the executive session on
house bill 1675.
that is the last bill i intend to exec
today i do have
one bill that i i have
here in front of me that i think we need
to have a little bit of discussion while
we have some time and that is house bill
1548 relating to the sale of lakes
region facility
this is the bill that carves out a piece
of the emergency
um
center that is on the on the uh the land
that is being proposed for sale
it's currently listed as about 17 acres
a couple buildings they may be looking
at
building another place
and the rest
if we were to adopt something we're
going to need an amendment to either
reduce the scope of the 17 acres
and i'll probably that would this is
graham talking at the moment not a
directive
and we definitely would need that if it
was sold
as currently
envisioned by
house bill 2 as part and parcel of the
sale
at least
a statement that some of the proceeds
from that
would go to building the new building
rather than going out and borrowing the
money to build a new building
for emergency services
i just want to know where what the will
of the committee is going forward and
looking at those issues because it will
any of that i have just been talking
about will take an amendment which we're
not going to try to get done today we've
got
a month or more to work on this
representative board
all right so laconia is my district um
i've had lots of conversations
with the municipal um
fire service as well as
all the parties involved
um
i'm strongly for itl on this to be
honest with you after the discussions
i've had it seems apparent to me they're
already working on relocating
the
existing building so i don't even feel
this is necessary at this point in time
uh the question i would have would be
how emergency state portion of the
emergency service is going to pay for
moving
i and that would
just a question you don't have to answer
because we're not going to execute at
this moment but i'm trying to get a
sense of the committee on where we're
going representative query
yeah um
since we heard this bill i did a little
research and i would be
wary of
uh shrinking that parcel down from the
17 acres it does seem like the sale of
the property would be better
at 17 acres than if we continually
chopped it down into smaller pieces plus
i will let
representative jack speak but he made
some points of uh some
like
equipment that he knows is on that
property that is pretty spread out
therefore making it kind of awkward to
carve it out but i would support an idea
of making sure that the sale proceeds of
that sale
go toward funding the new center
representative jack you got thrown under
the bus
thank you mr chairman uh there is there
is uh statewide communications equipment
on that property that was not
widely discussed at the hearing
uh and we need to make sure that that
that
if if it were moved it were done in such
a way that that isn't out of service
okay representative edgar
thank you mr chairman
i think this should be a little more
discussion on uh the fire service that's
there and if in fact they were forced to
move if there's any consideration for
for helping them with that move
thank you
represent me
mr chairman uh my concern
is
what was just mentioned and that
i'm a director of southwest new
hampshire fire mutual aid which is the
oldest and largest in the country
lakes region does a wonderful job i got
a concern that use we should not be
using state monies
for a private corporation that has
bonding ability and they could go out
to their towns they can change their fee
structure
i know in
southwest we floated a bond just a few
years ago to
buy the former keene fire department and
did a massive expansion in modernization
the facility
and it cost a little bit more for our
member communities but the cost is
more than worth it for everyone and i i
don't want to see a precedent start that
anytime a mutual aid system or a fire
fire service
is inconvenienced that they come to the
state to pay the bill
okay it looks like we have a
fairly wide range of of opinions on this
bill
um
we're not going to execute for probably
a couple of weeks
and i will let everybody know when we're
going to do that
um if you think that something should be
amended in the bill
i expect you to bring forward an
amendment at that point
um the motion
as always can be ought to pass out to
pass as amended or itl
and we can have that full and frank
discussion during an exact session i was
just trying to get
some sense of where the committee wanted
to go on it but i don't think we've
reached any kind of consensus at the
moment
but that will give us a chance to both
look at
the testimony that's been submitted both
in person and online on this issue
before we start making any decisions on
it
with that
we have about
10 minutes before we open our
full committee work session on house
bill 2022 relative to the 10-year
transportation plan
the committee is in recess until
10 35. thank
you i just had a question about the
other laconia 10 32 we didn't exec
we will exactly two of them at the same
time
i'd like to call the committee back to
order for our full committee work
session
on the 10-year transportation plan
and i call
call the committee to order
if
the clerk could was there anybody still
out there to have them come
in and what i'd like to do for the work
session is
invite the commissioner and or anybody
that she wants to send to the hot seat
uh to uh
to the table to to
work with us as we work through any
questions that we may have
where where i would like to start
if you recall from
the uh
presentation that the the department
gave us
last time around
during the public hearing slide 20 had
items for discussion
um i just want to make sure that we have
worked through all of those make sure
that we are where we are on them
and the first one up
is the
port authority functional replacement
commissioner we have the funds
to do that if i remember correctly with
what you said
all right you don't have to answer
you can let
anybody answer i i'll direct i'll
address you because you are there
um
so when we had advanced the draft
10-year plan in the gasset phase we
were still in the process of
applying for a grant
from
usdot unfortunately we did not secure
that grant and so
our current intention is to fully fund
this project with traditional formula
highway funds
uh thank you
um
any anybody else okay so that will be in
there
and something near and dear to
everybody's heart uh heart to include i
know the governor's um exit sign
renumbering project for tier one roads
which
which would renumber all of the
exits on the highways major highways
especially the interstates to the mile
markers
for example
the one for
uh lincoln would now be i think exit 100
rather than 32 if we were to go with
this my understanding
is that
there may be a penalty
because there's only two states that are
not going through this is that a real
threat or
can we just
go along with the gasset recommendation
of not to have this
remembering project within the 10-year
plan
so this has been a requirement of what's
called the mutcd the manual of uniform
traffic control devices for a long time
and while
there is a risk of a penalty um it has
never been
applied
so given the will of both gasset and the
governor to not include this project in
the 10-year plan
we would suggest that
we continue to
maintain our existing exit numbers and
if something was to change if federal
highway or usdot was to contact the
department then of course we'd bring
that information to this committee and
to others in the legislature at that
time
thank you
to the committee representative faulkner
just to clarify
is the money that would be
otherwise spent on the renumbering going
to be available for other projects or
was it something that was earmarked by
the feds
the money would be available for other
things we would have to fund this
project if we intended to comply with
the requirement
is it the will of the committee to go
along with the gas gasset
approval and not not include this in the
10-year plan
i see a lot of heads nodding okay thank
you just making sure we get hit them all
the
i-95 portsmouth sound walls are included
for the most part not to the complete
satisfaction of the city but they are
included within the
um
scope of
of this current 10-year plan
i do have
one
question that was brought to me
by the city
on
how do
they go about proposing a change
uh so that a thing like uh school
or whatever can be
used to qualify for
sound walls on tier one
roads
as you know we we're skipping a portion
of
a sound wall that they think is
important
so we have an existing noise policy
which is
applied to all of our projects
as you know
we could talk about sound walls a type 1
and a type 2
wall so type 1 walls or those that are
constructed as part of
a roadway project
we still have not funded a type 2
program which would allow us to go out
and build sound walls as standalone
projects
so the reason we are
proposing constructing walls in
portsmouth is because we're doing
a project in 95 to implement shoulder
running and because
we're advancing that work we did an
assessment of the sound
levels
and applied our policy criteria and then
identified that certain segments of wall
were warranted
we do continue to review and evaluate
our policy and we look at examples from
across the country as well as federal
guidelines as it pertains to noise
mitigation
and
we believe that we are applying sort of
the industry standards in this area and
but certainly if the legislature or
others want us to take a second look at
our policy
we
are always willing to
um see what flexibilities we do have as
a state
thank you representative query
uh thank you um
so just on the sound barrier like i
think i've mentioned it before and
potentially changing how we
allow for public spaces including
schools parks
and recreation areas
as far as i'm aware right now it's the
population density is measured
the full 24 7 not just daytime would
making an ex
exclusion or an exemption for
public spaces for just daytime
population density would that help
in matters like this school or parks
so that say like during the hours of 6
a.m to 6 p.m
um we can take a closer look at that but
i don't believe so representative um
the way that we
assess who is a receptor and then
evaluate the density of those receptors
i don't know that even if we
only looked at the criteria over the
daytime hours it would change the
outcome in terms of who qualifies for a
sound wall
thank you
as you know commissioner having sat
through
all this for a couple of years sidewalls
are
a big deal for many members of this
committee
i remember having to go to
the town of merrimack and
and
talk about the
being built in
um
yeah along the effie ever at about
i was in the minority and i still had to
go do it i don't understand that one but
um it's
it's still um
will continue to be a problem
um as as we
widen roads um traffic goes up so i
think that you and your successors we'll
continue to hear this almost along every
road that has
heavy traffic especially
and as
we develop more land along those routes
i don't see an easy solution and i think
at one point you said if we would put
them up every place that people think
it's it's in the 200 million range
so several years ago we had done a study
and we looked at across the entire
network
if you apply today's standards to
our highway system in what locations
would qualify for a sound wall
and so as we're doing projects as we're
widening highways you know in the case
of this project
in portsmouth on 95
people are always looking for us to
broaden the criteria so that as part of
that project we construct more walls
but we keep emphasizing that even under
the existing criteria there are
communities that would be deserving of a
sound wall the issue is we don't have a
funded type 2 program a
funding to go out and do standalone
projects purely to install sound walls
and so we're very concerned about this
from an equity perspective
um
while we're sympathetic to those who
have advocated for additional walls
within projects
we are just as sympathetic to those
communities who have noise problems
today there is no work planned in their
area and therefore there is no sound
wall proposed despite the fact they do
meet the density requirements etc etc so
we try to bring attention to both issues
um the fact that individuals would like
more walls as part of projects but that
we also have
many many locations that would be
deserving of a sound wall following the
current criteria we just don't have the
necessary funding
i reserve thompson
commissioner thank you for coming again
today
is the criteria different for turnpikes
than it is for
the highway system in general or
and the reason i ask is
i went down the spalding turnpike the
other day from dover toll to great bay
and they've got these what i consider to
be horrendous walls it's like you're
driving through downtown
well not downtown maybe just anywhere in
new jersey
the walls go up
14 or 18 feet high you can't see the
neighborhoods and i just didn't see the
justification for it there
and we're a tourist state we want people
to see the things around the highways
as well as
and i sympathize with these people who
live in these neighborhoods but
down in great bay in particular we
should
not be putting up this many of these
walls we apply the same standards to all
projects um the difference is we've done
extensive widening on the spalding
turnpike therefore we've assessed noise
and then built the sound walls as part
of those projects you know likewise as
we widened i-93 from salem to manchester
for those areas that qualified we built
sound walls
as i mentioned there's
locations elsewhere in the state where
we haven't done a project and so the
sections of 101 and sections of 93
beyond where we did the widening project
that would be eligible for sound walls
so we apply consistent criteria
why you don't see it in other locations
as those sections were widened before
the sound criteria was in place okay
thank you
representative abbott
yes
i'm i should be able to recall but
unfortunately as i age
that becomes more of a problem
but what is the life expectancy
for the existing sound walls that we
have
so that is one of our current challenges
that not only do we have inadequate
funding to build additional walls and
we're now at a point where we're trying
to
understand what the maintenance and
repair needs are for existing systems so
i'm going to ask pete to talk to that
pete stamnis director of project
development
we understand that most of the walls
affect all of the walls that have been
constructed
within the last 20 years
along
the highways as part of type 1
policy
are
made from wood
and certainly there's a life
span of that material we haven't begun
replacing them yet but it's on the
horizon
and because of that we've made a recent
change that we're
finalizing
and that
the wood walls would then become
in in new installations would become
precast concrete to extend the overall
life
span
of the walls themselves and we find that
they're
if you look at the life cycle costs that
this change would uh be
cost savings overall to the state so
that's that's where we're headed
that's where we're headed
representative claudia
thank you mr chairman and i i i'm going
to ask the question i wanted to ask this
morning if you don't mind
i'm concerned about the funding the
proper funding of sowell some of the
proposed sound walls are going to be
built along turnpike some are going to
be built along highways
is it
are you required when building a saw
well for example it's along a turnpike
to only use funds from the turnpike
system
for those type of sound walls or
barriers and then for those built along
highways are you only supposed to use
highway funds
to erect those barriers and is it
legal or constitutional
to mix the funds just out of curiosity
so when we are advancing a federal
project then
through the environmental permitting
process we're required to look at noise
impacts
and then we can use federal funds to
construct the sound walls
where there's restrictions is for
example we could never use turnpike
money
beyond the turnpike the dollars
collected on the turnpike system can
only be used on the turnpike system
however we can use federal funds on the
turnpike we can also use state funds on
the turnpike but many times we choose
not to
the reason being if we use any federal
funds on a section of turnpike then
federal rules will be applied to that
section of turnpike in perpetuity
because we accepted federal funding so
there are many advantages to continuing
to maintain control of the sections of
roadway
that were turnpike before the
federal-aid highway system was
established
and so representative as an example i-95
we're choosing to fund the sound walls
on 95 with federal funds
because i-95 was part of the state
highway system
for a long time we used federal funds on
95 in the past and then
for those of you that have been on the
committee for a longer time you'll
remember that we actually sold the i-95
bridge to the turnpike and made it part
of the turnpike system so having already
used federal funds we have no concern
about using federal funds for the sound
walls even though we're advancing the
shoulder running project with turnpike
dollars
um so the only strict prohibition is we
cannot use turnpike funding beyond the
turnpike
um we technically can use federal and
state funds on the turnpike system
but there are reasons why we would
choose not to
all right okay thank you commissioner
representative faulkner
thank you
the
question i have is do you have a
standard design where you put a wall in
is always
to a standard design and is there any
pressure to kind of
upgrade the aesthetics uh which i
imagine would also upgrade the cost or
are people just happy to get some
something to block the noise
um as pete indicated one of the things
we're pursuing is
replacing
our wooden walls with concrete when the
time comes because we are looking at the
life expectancy and the life cycle costs
but yes as we work with communities
there is concerns about aesthetics
um
you know in particular we've seen a lot
of graffiti on some of our sound walls
and trying to keep up with graffiti
removal is challenging
so
certainly there's discussions about
whether or not it's appropriate to put
in plantings or things that would
discourage people from accessing the
sound walls
and so we do take that into
consideration
but
you know from our perspective it's about
um life cycle cost and what is the most
prudent solution
um from that perspective i don't know
pete if there's anything you want to add
there will be opportunities to enhance
the
the look of the
sound wall the most visible portion of
it with a transition to
precast concrete
there are things that can be done
but we haven't really we haven't
massachusetts puts them in that way and
they do have some panel
liners that they can that can
put a
different surface you know texture to
the panel itself and there have been
some you probably noticed in
in a couple of locations um they had
supplied a a
precast concrete panel with a you know
state of new hampshire
put on the panel itself there's one i
think in in the newington dover project
on the uh on the dover side and i think
there might be one on i-93 also so
there's opportunities to do things uh
everything comes with a cost of course
uh thank you um i have
two questions uh on separate things um
one would be
just off of what we're talking about now
for aesthetic reasons
um and
anti-graffiti
uh
it whatever you want to call that um
have you
thought or have you allowed communities
to put together
um
projects where
murals could be painted on these because
i do know that that's quite successful
at stopping people from
tagging um in case you all didn't know i
do have a degree in art so it's it is
something that i
uh know quite well um
and these don't have to be detailed
because obviously we don't want to make
it too distracting that people start
staring at the wall instead of paying
attention to road conditions
but
just kind of a general painting
is that allowed um so that's something
that we have discussed if we go to a
concrete standard and it's precast then
maybe we don't do the form liners that
pete described and give texture to the
panel if it was a flat surface then
maybe we could work with communities on
murals in addition to
what pete described where we embossed
the state seal or something into a panel
um other parts of the country they have
had some success
what they found is that
um for the true graffiti artists they
are artists as well that they won't
destroy somebody else's work um so
murals have
held up over time
of course it depends on the location how
accessible it is but we definitely would
have more opportunity to look at that if
we're using concrete over wood
great
um and then my second question is
i've just been reading some articles
about the effectiveness of basically the
throw of the sound that
as you get to about
500 feet
away from the wall
um
they are ineffective
at that point which um
you know seems like we're putting up a
lot of money just for the houses that
are right next to the highway
um but whereas
natural or soft um sound barriers like
shrubs trees and other things like that
is
is the reason why we don't look into
that more is that because of a safety
reason of having a giant tree right next
to the highway and now you have a an
obstacle that may fall or
drop branches or other debris
so i would say it's much more likely
that we're trying to limit the
environmental impacts so
if you imagine we're doing a widening
project we're going to have to clear
trees to install the additional travel
lane or the
wider shoulder
and so
if we don't have the right-of-way
between the limits of the project and
the houses then we're putting up that
wall because it's
the smallest footprint and provides the
highest degree of benefit in terms of
reducing sound we don't typically have
the width to then
widen the highway in addition put in
trees and adequate plantings to truly
mitigate noise
and i i think um you would need probably
a couple hundred feet of of trees in
order to get the same effectiveness from
a sound
abatement standpoint
representative gadhafi on sound walls
thank you
have you ever considered
i know i was a contractor i designed
commercial industrial buildings we had
problems with sound
we used abba vitis now the advantage to
abba bodies as opposed to trees
is they grow all the way to the ground
you plant them six feet apart
in the second row
alternating
in six feet this way
nothing that even small animals can't
get through
and it's an effective sound barrier
i don't know about the cost of it but
have you done any studies with that
i grow too about i don't know that we've
looked um specifically at the cost and
what it would mean but
um
i don't believe it has the same noise
benefits that constructing these walls
do and that's why it's not an accepted
practice
as pete said that the depth that we
would need for the level of um
noise mitigation required for the
traffic volumes that we're talking about
on these high-speed facilities um i
don't know that it
would be a viable solution in this
setting i think in lower volume areas
along developments and such it can be
effective but we're talking about you
know high speed high volume
interstate corridors and the like
we have
used uh plantings of that nature um to
improve the visual
view from those
community or those neighborhoods that
don't qualify for sound walls so on on
many occasions we've had uh double rows
of plantings of of uh fur trees
arborvitaes
not so much mainly because the deer like
them a lot but um but we have done that
um as a as a
consolation i guess you could say
because they didn't qualify for sound
abatement
it just seems it has a lot of benefits
it improves the value it's good to look
at from the highway improves the value
of the property at the same time
i just think you know if the noise is
that
that level maybe a third row i don't
know i've never done a third row
but it seems as though this you know
that a lot of places have used
aberfaities
because they do go all the way to the
ground
and they're so dense inside
anyway that's all i have to say
dennis
um
i agree with with representative fidolfi
i've been in the construction business
45 years worked many
years on the highways
and
we did install berms
with abervides sometimes we did
adverbities with a
um as he suggested offset with a fence
down the middle and no it doesn't
it doesn't give you the same uh
sound retention that these walls that
you've put up with
would
but in many cases i think
it would just make the people feel
better that you've made an effort
in maybe what is a limited right of way
in a neighborhood
you know and i can think of one in
particular in bedford
um
my uh
the second part of my question is have
you done any testing on the back side of
these walls
to see what the actual sound reduction
is
i mean obviously there's going to be
some but is it
sufficient
to warrant the
millions of dollars that we spend on
these things
we do thorough sound analysis so yes we
put um equipment out and we measure the
existing sound levels and then we
have done post construction monitoring
that's why we now have able to identify
locations in the state that would
qualify for sound walls if we had a type
2 program
the sound reduction is noticeable if
you've ever
one place that i walked recently there's
a path along the
dover side of the new dover project
um that was behind a sound wall and
you know
before and afters it's it's noticeable
and it does um there
there the way it works is it basically
creates a
i think somewhat coined it as a as a uh
a sound shadow
so based on the height of the wall and
the you know sound travels in a straight
line so it creates a a shadow and that
that the areas behind the wall that are
within that shadow would get the benefit
of the sound and as you go further away
you get less of a benefit so that's
just one little further question if i
may mr speaker um a number quite a
chairman not speaker but
um
quite a number of years ago there was a
system constructed down by candia road
on 101 i think mitchy corporation built
those
i can only think to call them a hog
trough
where they sat inside of each other and
there were
there was some biology built into the
built into that too i wondered i've
never seen one since i wondered what
happened to that
system it's called an evergreen wall and
the only way it stays green is if you
water it
and that's uh part of the problem okay
is the long-term maintenance
thank you
representative edgar
thank you mr chairman
and uh thanks for taking my question
i'm back to the m back to the portsmouth
uh sound walls
and
i was wondering has there been a cost
estimate for what it would take to
actually fill a gap around the school to
put
a uh
sound wall system in
i'd be interested to know one of the
reasons is because the chairman said if
you're going to try to make any
additions or changes you had to
be able to give something up or make
some kind of suggestion so
i don't believe that we have run an
accurate cost estimate for what it would
um
we'd have to budget
to cover the cost of that location
what we have been cautioning is if we
deviate from the policy
because we have done this analysis
across the state of all the locations
that qualify for sound walls if we were
to build this section in portsmouth then
there are many many other communities
that would be making the case that they
too should receive a sound wall
and so
as i said we're trying to follow the
policy and even following that policy
we're not able to mitigate noise in all
of the communities that would be
deserving um
and
i think representative you asked the
question earlier what is the order of
magnitude at the time that we had looked
at the 49
50 or so locations that would meet the
criteria
um it's
it was going to be approximately 120.
25 130 million um
but that's dated information now if we
were to apply today's dollars
it probably would be closer to
million dollars just to tackle those
locations that currently meet standards
follow-up thank you mr chairman
um well one of the reasons i asked is i
i know that uh you provided us
information in the past it was a pretty
thick packet
that
mentioned the different criteria and
where the needs were
throughout the state but you are working
right now in that area and it kind of
makes it a little bit different in a way
to me anyway
at least to consider it and that's why i
asked the question so uh thank you for
your answer thank you mr chairman
thank you i think that we have
talked a lot about sound walls and
construction there are sound walls
within the 10-year plan
if we want to move them around remember
that this is a zero-sum game
if we move something into a given year
we have to move something out with the
equivalent dollars
it makes our job a little tougher if we
want to make any changes
um
but it's not impossible for us to do um
the governor and the the executive
council has proposed
uh uh plan and we have that draft but we
can work on that
um
let's go to
hudson's circumvention highway
i know that it was not included in the
draft
but i also know that there are
representatives of of hudson who are
working hard to try to get it put back
into the plan
as it goes through the legislative
process
can you explain how how it could be
funded or not be funded or what you know
about it at this point commissioner
so on tuesday evening i was made aware
that a number of the reps in hudson are
interested in having the circumferential
added to the 10-year plan
i'll be honest i have not had a chance
to reach out to any of the
representatives from hudson to talk
about what their request would be
i'm not sure if they're
asking that the project be
added back into the 10-year plan using
the funding assumptions
that were associated with the project
when it was last in the 10-year plan
previously what was discussed was the
town of hudson advancing
a conceptual design
and then
submitting applications for some of the
discretionary grant programs to access
the dollars to construct the wall
or sorry to construct the project
this is a challenging location
the hudson boulevard would be located
on a portion of the layout that was
identified for the circumferential
highway
which was a roadway project that was
never constructed
the circumferential was supposed to
connect from
the nashua hudson area up to litchfield
and be a true circumferential roadway to
the turnpike
so some of the land that has been
acquired was purchased with turnpike
dollars
and so hudson boulevard would only be a
very small piece of what was envisioned
for the entire circumferential
and would not necessarily have benefit
to the turnpike system
and so that's why there was hesitation
in the past to fund that project with
turnpike funds
also we've just delayed a number of our
turnpike projects because of the revenue
impacts during the clover 19 pandemic so
for example exit six and seven on 293
has been delayed the bill conquered
widening project has been delayed
and so
that factors into the
the use of turnpike dollars
so that would leave us with either
federal funds or state funds
as this committee knows we have very
limited state funds
so that would be an impact to our
betterment program if we were to fund
this project
and then the use of federal funds
is challenging
um if if we were to program federal
dollars for the design and then not move
to construction would be
perhaps subject to payback and have to
pay federal highway back for those
federal dollars
so i really need more time since we have
a work session scheduled for next week
i'd like to talk to the representatives
from hudson understand exactly what
their thoughts are and then come back to
the committee next week when i know a
little bit more
i i would appreciate that because
otherwise we could end up with floor
amendments when house bill 2022 comes to
the floor and if we don't have um
accurate information to
either support or
fight any type of amendment that might
come forward
it would be helpful just so that we have
the background
background with it um keeping an open
mind that i understand that every town
wants to if something is dropped out
they want to get it back in
so
that would be useful i thank you for
that answer and we will look forward to
the information
representative jack
uh thank you uh as best you know is this
uh the work that's being talked about
totally within the town of hudson
because there's also the part
that would go to the that the uh exit
nine is reserved for to go across the
river that's not being talked about i
would assume
this would purely be in the town of
hudson um really they're trying to
address the level of congestion on
lowell road which is 3a
by providing an alternate route within
the town of hudson
i just want to be clear the department
was not the lead on this project it was
the town that had hired a consultant to
scope out the project
they did submit a grant application
they applied for a bill grant from usdot
a few years ago
my recollection is that they were
estimating the design to be about 4
million and the construction at that
time to be 45 million
um but they had really not advanced the
design
um
to a level where you'd have high
confidence in the budget i think that
was one of the reasons they weren't
successful in securing the bill grant
um
they wanted more confidence around the
true cost so
having not managed this project you know
the the prior 10-year plan project and
the authority that it was granted to the
department was purely to work with the
town of hudson and support them
we'd have to talk to the town about what
the current estimate would be for either
design or construction
um thank you
representative
you just mentioned the concord widening
and being delayed
is there any way whether the new federal
funds or anything else comes along that
we can
figure out anything to advance and
accelerate the concord widening it just
as a tourist state that's got to be one
of the greatest embarrassments there are
on any given friday afternoon
particularly during the summer time
uh the back up into the city of
manchester as far as the city of
manchester and beyond it rivals
traffic jams i've been in dc or la or
multiple other cities it's it's a state
embarrassment
so
currently um
the turnpike ends at exit 14.
and so this project would be
both federally and turnpike funded um so
for example the interchange between 89
and 93 would be federally funded because
89 is not part of the turnpike
and then all of the work beyond exit 14
which would include the merrimack
river bridge crossing that would all be
eligible for federal funding so while
yes we have significant
increases in our federal funds
we also had a lot of other needs that
came up during the 10-year plan process
and
given where our turnpike revenues were
at and the lack of available dollars for
the sections that are turnpike funded
and that was why the decision was made
to push out the bill concord project and
we really didn't hear a lot of advocacy
during the 10-year plan hearings for
that project to be
done sooner
so you know we intend to work with the
city of concord get the layout for the
project approved
and then we do think that this would be
a good candidate for some of the
discretionary grant programs and so
there's been a lot of safety concerns
with the interchange between 89 and 93.
if we have the layout approved for the
entire corridor and can advance the
environmental permitting
then we'd be well positioned to compete
for discretionary grants so that's our
current thought
but the we still caution if we were to
use federal funds on the turnpike
section
then the federal strings that come with
that
um
might
pose some concern so that's the piece
that we have to keep discussing as we
move forward but certainly we would
attempt to secure federal grants for the
federal portions and do those sooner
and we always intended to break that
project into multiple phases and it was
never going to be one single
construction contract
thank you commissioner and the last one
on on that the items for discussion from
last time
near and dear to some people especially
one of the executive councilors
balsams the gulf links road
my understanding
is that
one is not in the draft plan and that if
we were to do anything with it
we would have to
come up with i forget i forget the exact
number somewhere around four million
dollars to do
if i remember correctly
so what are your thoughts on doing that
as we go forward
or not or just leave it the way gasset
proposed and not have it in the 10-year
plan it it's a policy decision i
understand but
it has financial implications for your
department if we do something
um so at the
hearing last week when we spoke to this
project you know i explained it's not
eligible for federal funding this would
have to be state funded
as we've discussed
our betterment dollars are limited
and especially when sb 367 revenue goes
to the principal payments for the i-93
construction
then we
will be further hampered in terms of the
level investment we can make on our tier
three and four roads that aren't
eligible for federal funds
so we would
not recommend the use of highway funds
but as i said the other day you know
this is a policy decision if the
legislature wanted to use general funds
or another category of funding that
would be
your decision to make but we would not
advocate for the use of highway funds
given how our revenues were impacted
both during the covet 19 pandemic
as well as the timing of this request
with the
the principal payments kicking in a
couple of years for the i-93 work
to your knowledge of the rules
uh federal rules would this be eligible
if fiscal and or the governor and
council or whomever wanted to use arpa
funds
for that project
would it even be eligible and again it
would be a policy decision to do that
but is it feasible
um i am not as well versed on the
allowable uses of arp um when it comes
to the
the most flexible categories um i do
know that we as a state did suffer lost
revenue
and arpa funds can be used to replace
lost revenue so perhaps a case could be
made if it was something the legislature
wanted to pursue then certainly we would
work with goford understand eligibility
and
i have talked to commissioner caswell
previously about just in general what
highway projects might be eligible
but we've never pursued any so we'd have
to follow up with his office
thank you um
i know that you
mentioned to me
about a request from
a community
in regards to
um
toll credits
as me everybody on the committee should
realize the only way we do
use any of the federal highway funds we
get is to match them with toll credits
if you could just go through quickly
what not or as much time as you want
actually we got all day
the
what the request is
and what your thoughts is commissioner
are on the request
so first of all i'll start by explaining
what toll credits are and how they work
just to make sure that the committee has
a thorough understanding of the program
um so toll credits are as the name
suggests a credit they are not cash
so most of our federal programs are
funded
um 80 with federal funds and then we
have to provide a 20
cash match to access those federal funds
so simple terms the federal government
gives you eighty dollars we add twenty
dollars of cash we spend a hundred
dollars
however here in new hampshire we do not
use cash match for the state
funded projects
so what does that mean well the turnpike
system as we alluded to earlier predates
the national highway system
many sections of turnpike were
constructed
before the interstate system and the nhs
were fully built out
so what happens is when we invest on the
spalding turnpike
or invest on i-95
and use the revenue that we have
generated within the state
the federal government gives us credit
for that because we're choosing to
generate our own revenue and keep that
system in a good state of repair and not
drawing on federal funds to do it
so the more we spend on the turnpike
system the more credits we accrue from
the federal government
and the last uh
presentation we gave you we had showed
what the total credit balances were for
the state
but as i said they're just a credit it's
just a reward for not drawing on federal
funds to maintain a significant portion
of the national highway system
so what happens today
is if
we're given 80 from the federal
government for a state managed project
we apply 20 of toll credits but they
have no value all they do is allow us to
access the federal funds so instead of
spending a hundred dollars
we only spend eighty so we have the
eighty dollars of federal money twenty
dollars of toll credits with no cash
value so we only spend 80.
so this is one of the challenges for us
to state and you know when you look at
how
our condition of our infrastructure is
changing over time compared to say our
neighbors vermont
vermont gets more federal funds to begin
with but then they also because they
don't have a turnpike system they don't
have toll credits to use
so they always bring a 20 match to the
table
so they're spending significantly more
on their network every year
so the request that has come in
um the town of keene or sorry the city
of keene reached out
in the recently passed
infrastructure bill the iija
there is a provision to allow states to
sell their surplus toll credits to other
states
and so
what's authorized in the bill is for the
usdot to establish a toll credit
marketplace pilot
so
as we alluded to last time
because of the work that we've done on
the turnpike system over the last
several years we talked about the
widening of the spalding in newington
and dover we had accrued some pretty
significant total credit balances
because it's not cash
even after we've matched every penny of
federal funds we still have these
credits available
so
what other states who don't have credits
have expressed interest in is buying
toll credits from a state like new
hampshire for maybe you know 20 cents or
50 cents on the dollar
why would that be a value to us well
that would take a credit that's worth
nothing and actually turn it into cash
we would have more money to spend on our
system
why would a state want to do that well
we just received a lot more federal
authorization so a state like vermont is
scrambling right now to work with their
legislature to secure the match to
access those federal dollars
so they might choose to buy toll credits
so that they wouldn't have to provide as
much cash to access the federal funds so
those states who are at risk of leaving
federal money on the table because they
can't come up with the match
might want to buy the credits even
though it would mean they spend less
overall
so keane i think had misunderstood the
language in the iija
they were wondering why would you sell
toll credits to a neighboring state why
wouldn't you just give the toll credits
to
municipalities to use
but what they hadn't understood is when
we use them within the state we still
only get so much federal funding
so what i explained to the city of keene
is
i can't just give them toll credits
so for example if they had a 10 million
dollar project
typically you'd get 8 million of federal
funding and the city of keene in this
case because it's a town managed project
or municipal managed project would
provide a two million dollar match
the toll credits have no value
so if i gave them two million in toll
credits
we still only have eight million dollars
of federal funds so i said it was not a
decision that new hampshire d.o.t could
make that i would bring it to the
legislature
because in reality if their project
still costs 10 million
we don't just have to spend 2 million in
total credits
we have to spend an additional million
in total credits to be able to convert
that 8 million to 10 million of federal
funds
and the additional 2 million of federal
funds would have to come from another
project or program
so it's not a zero-sum game here we
essentially would be adding federal
funds to their project
which
as you have said several times mr
chairman you know as soon as we add
money to one project we're taking it
from something else so the department
didn't want to be
making those types of choices if this is
something that the legislature supported
because municipalities were truly
struggling to come up with match
then it would be a decision for you all
as a policy body not for the department
um so that was what we did i educated i
replied to keen and really educated them
on how the toll credits truly work i
think this misunderstanding stems from
the changes that were implemented in the
iija
and i can understand at first glance you
know why would we sell things to states
if we could give them to our own
municipalities
but the unfortunate thing is they have
zero value um when we use them within
the state so you'd have to add federal
funds to the project
so i know this is very complicated and
this is why i think the city didn't
fully understand it so if there's any
questions i can go back through how they
work again this is something that we've
covered many times both with this
committee but then also with the capital
budget overview committee
because that's the other piece of this
anytime we use toll credits for a
non-traditional purpose
we go to the capital budget overview
committee for their concurrence
thank you questions about
representative thompson
um
you've said repeatedly that the credits
have no value
how would we sell them to another state
and what would we get for those credits
so the reason they have no value within
the state is because we get a fixed
amount of federal funds every year okay
and so if i convert the credits or try
to use the credits
i'm not gaining federal money i'm just
being able to access that money without
providing a cash match
if we sold them to another state it
would be up to that state to adjust the
federal funding on their projects they
would truly be giving us cash so that's
why it would be beneficial if we have
very high balances far beyond what we
need to access federal dollars if after
every single penny of federal money that
we're spending has been matched we still
have
you know 250 or 300 million dollars with
the tool credits then there would be
value in selling them to another state
because they would give us actual cash
but it's unlikely they're going to give
us dollar for dollar
this is why they want to establish a
marketplace to see what the market value
of them might be would it be 10 cents 20
cents 30 cents
and
that's one of the things i know
senator waters and others are interested
in new hampshire being one of the states
to participate in the pilot
but our total credit balances aren't as
healthy today as they once were
because we
aren't investing in the turnpike at the
same rate based on the turnpike revenues
declining and so we do have some updated
information that we probably would want
to bring to the committee
at the next work session to have a
conversation about our participation in
the pilot but that's a separate decision
um first and foremost we wanted to talk
about keane's request
and the thing that we're concerned about
is if we granted this to keem then other
municipalities who
currently are required to provide a 20
match for a locally administered project
might ask for the same thing so then it
wouldn't just be about funding this one
ask
it could have a significant impact um
and overall the state would spend less
instead of us taking the federal money
and adding a 20 match we'd only be
spending the federal money so the
investment in transportation would be
less
representative jack
uh thank you mr chairman uh commissioner
is there a time limit for us to decide
whether we want to participate in the
pilot uh does we have to do it before we
enact
the 10-year plan
the toll
credit
marketplace pilot
um
was only just authorized in the iija
there's been no guidance yet released by
federal highway or usdot as to how they
intend to advance that program we're
eagerly awaiting that guidance to
understand what the time frames might be
and how that would impact us in our
preparation
representative ebel
thank you this is actually a really
simple request um many of us have taken
many notes on toll credits and how they
work for a really long time if if you
if you have a letter that you wrote to
keene that sort of goes through the
whole litany
if you could provide it to the committee
i'd appreciate having it i mean we may
have
inquiries from our own municipalities
that we represent and it would be right
there for us to refer to yes i can
certainly provide you with a copy that'd
be terrific thank you
representative eaton
commissioner i sir done capital budget
oversight for years so i used to have a
pretty
accurate rundown on a yearly basis
on what our current bank account is and
toll credits
do you have a rough number where we're
at at the current moment
we had provided
um
in our first presentation to this
committee
uh the balances that were forecast back
in october
um as i mentioned we've been doing some
work to
revise our projections
so we'd like to come back to the
committee at the next work session with
updated data
the big difference between october and
today is of course the iij was passed
because we're now getting more federal
money
we're going to have to spend more toll
credits to access those dollars
so we had to factor in
that aspect to our calculations but then
in addition with the concurrence from
gaset and the governors
to delay the
spending on the turnpike projects that
further impacts how quickly we're going
to accrue toll credits so we've been
crunching the numbers i think we were a
little bit over um
ambitious in our
october projections again not
understanding how much federal money we
were going to be receiving
we thought that by 2026 our balances
might be as high as 250 million
we're thinking right now it's probably
closer to 180 but we need another week
or so to refine the numbers and then
we'll bring you an updated um
table with what we're currently
projecting for balances at the next work
session
thank you i i think that that would be
useful
because
i know that the department routinely
at the end of each federal fiscal year
searches for states that have not been
able to use all of their
federal highway funds to to so that we
can bring
projects along
quicker and we would need to have
that match
um if we were to go and say well vermont
didn't use all of their money or
whatever state
we could use another 20 40 50 million
dollars for something
um
so that will be very helpful to to know
projections not knowing how much money
we may get
at the end of any given fiscal year
so yes that is the value of toll credits
unlike other states we don't have to
come back to the legislature and request
additional state funds when there is
opportunities to access federal dollars
because we have this authorization to
use total credits we can pursue what
they call redistribution when they redis
redistribute authority to states at the
end of the year based on available
balances but also the discretionary
grants we can pursue the grants knowing
that we'll always have the total credits
to be able to access those additional
dollars so it is terrific that we have
these balances but yes it's not just
what we project based on what's
currently programmed we do need to hold
back enough tool credits to be able to
access redistribution and we've been
receiving around 20 million on average
each year
in redistribution so that requires four
million dollars of total credits
annually potentially
so over a five-year period that's
another 20 million would want to hold in
reserve
or more because there might be more
redistribution opportunities on the
discretionary grant side that's what's
hard to project to
project is what will we actually receive
in grants and there's a lot more
discretionary funding in this
transportation bill than there was in
past bills so we'd want to hold back
credits be able to access those dollars
so
that's why we're
um updating the projections right now on
what's needed to match the projects
currently in the 10-year plan
and then we'll be talking with this
committee and with senate transportation
should we decide to participate in the
pilot
how many toll credits would we even want
to sell how many should we be holding in
reserve so that we can continue to be
nimble and secure the additional federal
funds when they're available
senator thompson
if we um
are considering selling these credits to
to other states and we have cities like
keane
that have asked to use them
and correct me if i'm wrong based on a
project where they've applied
for federal funds and need the match
money is that correct
they haven't applied it's not a grant
they are using
formula funds but it's one of the
categories where it's a locally
administered project
so
we have a number of programs the
transportation alternatives program the
congestion mitigation air quality
program where we do solicitations
and
municipalities can compete for those
dollars so they're regular federal
formula funds that we distribute to the
cities and towns so this is a
municipally managed project that is
funded with formula funds
i guess my question is
would we not be better off to use those
credits
on municipal and
in city projects which would improve the
overall
highway system in new hampshire
with
many of the roads that uh i'm going to
go through the example one more time
because this is complicated this is i
think why keen is misunderstood so
and representative ebal i certainly will
share this letter so you have it in
front of you but if so using the example
of a 10 million dollar project
if we have a 10 million dollar project
then
the typical arrangement would be 8
million of federal funds with 2 million
of cash match from the municipality
toll credits have no value so i can't
just switch out two million dollars for
two million dollars of credit i have to
add two million dollars of federal funds
to make that project whole
so so that means you've got to find the
two million dollars from another project
and that's why we didn't believe it was
a decision the department should make to
take federal funds from another project
that's something we'd bring to
the legislature or to gasset or the
governor depending on what phase we were
in to be honest with the 10-year plan
um
unlike if we sold them to a neighboring
state if we sold two million dollars
worth of toll credits to vermont
and they gave us
this would be ambitious but 50 cents on
the dollar i would get a million dollars
of cash i could then give that cash to
the city of keene to reduce their match
which is different than trying to use
total credits within your state
okay i guess that's what i was asking
why we couldn't use
the money to help the cities and towns
so if we participate in the marketplace
and we're able to turn our credits into
cash well then we could work with the
legislature to program those additional
dollars
and determine how you'd want to spend
them
thank you very much
um right at the moment i want to take a
little bit of time break for lunch
i'm commissioner we have we will we'll
get more into individual
projects the turnpike system and all the
rest
but
so far we have neglected rail and
aeronautics
but we we do need to cover those either
today or at the next work session i
don't know which is more convenient to
do just to go through what's in the
10-year plan so that we know
what it what is going on
and then also
um you alluded to it and talked a little
bit about it last time
the 17 million dollars for
ev
infrastructure and when i look through
it's a lot of planning but also
construction
um
and how will that
be
don't answer now when when we reconvene
how will the legislature
know what is going on with that planning
and where it will be and what the the
backbone will be and all the rest
because that
feeds into all the other things that we
heard this morning about alternative
fuels and
and fees and all the rest
um so we certainly can talk about
aeronautics rail and transit um today if
you want to break for lunch and we're
available
um i can reach out to director hurlihi
and see if he's able to join us for this
afternoon session or shelly winters or
trish lambert who are the administrators
for the rail and transit and aeronautics
bureaus respectively
this is a multimodal transportation plan
the reason we spend a lot of time
talking about highway projects is
because we can only use federal funds
for
rehab renewal and reconstruction
projects we cannot use federal funds for
routine operations
and because of the
size of the federal highway program
there's a lot of decisions to be made
what you'll hear from the rail and
transit advocates and from
the airports to some degrees a lot of
the federal funding they're receiving is
for their routine operations and so the
funds are being
used to maintain the existing services
there's not as many decisions to be made
and then with the capital dollars that
we do receive there's separate
discretionary or sorry separate grant
programs that we have to follow to
distribute those dollars um so we
certainly can go back through the
different categories of money make sure
you understand the different
federal programs in more detail we
really went through that very quickly in
our first presentation
but there's just less opportunity for
the legislature to influence how those
dollars are spent and that's why we
spend so much time talking about
the highway projects in particular and
so we can talk about that today and then
as i explained last time you know we
don't have a lot of information yet
about the ev charging programs but we
certainly can talk about
what work the department's doing
the conversations we've been having with
the transportation council that was
established as well as the legislation
that senator waters has sponsored
and what decisions this committee might
want to make in that area
i guess i lost the bubble on that last
one but
what legislation is in the senate but um
if if you could have
the rail and transit folks here at one
o'clock and we can go through that it
should not be
all that long
but
it's imperative that this committee at
least understand what is
in the entire book
because there will be times when people
will ask
why are we funding an airport in maine
which has come up before
but it's
imperative that we at least go through
and understand where the money is from
and what it's going for
over the next decade
um and i know that yes everybody sees
roads and highways and bridges because
we travel on them all the time and that
is
the biggest impact but this committee
has a responsibility to also look at at
all the rest
and and
at least
have an understanding if not a complete
um
acknowledgement of of all the work that
gets done in the background of of all of
that
so with that
i'd ask those committee members who
so desire to come back and finish this
at one o'clock
i will say one thing
if you want to have
anything changed or added or
whatever in this 10-year plan as a
member of the committee
you have to bring it in in writing we
can talk about it
but it i need it in writing
as an amendment to house bill 2022
so that we can talk about
it as a committee
i know that there will be amendments
brought in i think the
department will probably have at least
one because we have to change numbers of
bonding and authority and and all the
rest we we do that and everyone
but
we need to
do that as we go along if you have an
amendment done up
we can talk about it
do a straw poll
on whether or not we want to adopt it
because we only have one amendment at
the end of the process just like any
other bill
so the straw polls are just that
um to work on it so that we know what we
have to start putting together
for the final thing
one thing this year that we are
well ahead of where we've been in some
prior years
we have until
first part of march to get this finished
i'd like to get it finished by the end
of february
a lot of you probably saw the email that
came out yesterday
i did have to change one meeting from
the 17th of february to the next week
as i told you at one point there will be
a house session the week of the 15th and
that thursday
and my estimation is probably probably
is
um
going to be one of the day or days that
we meet
i don't know where
but
rather than waiting until that week to
change it i'm just changing i hadn't had
a change now for planning purposes
and
even after that
which would include the uh an exec
session in 2022 if we can't agree on
amendment we'll come back on another day
um it's just that simple
um
but commissioner i do
appreciate you and your staff taking all
of this time
even
more so than i think any of us can
express
and with that we'll be in recess until
one o'clock
thank you very much
bob you coming
r represents the birds you
want to come back and talk or
okay
yeah all right
if we could
reassemble and continue the work session
i did um
commissioner to
um
talk briefly about
or as long as you all have
questions about rail transit and uh
aeronautics and where we are and how
much
um
is within the
scope of the current intermodal plan and
that's what this is
so that we should know what's going on
and
commissioner
is just briefly go over
and i think they're broken out by
projects and probably better on your
maps
i i don't
it's just i won't tell you what to do
um well good afternoon thank you for
having us back this afternoon um joining
me today is uh shelly winters who's the
administrator for the bureau of rail and
transit
unfortunately director patrick hurlehy
and
trish lambert who's the administrator
for the bureau of aeronautics are both
at a conference today
so
i brought shelley so we could address
more of your rail and transit questions
i will do my best to field all things
aeronautics but of course we have
another work session next week if
necessary i can have
patrick or trisha come with me
and we can certainly follow up with any
questions that you might have
so i was going to skip over aeronautics
for now and focus on transit first of
all and i don't know if folks have a
copy of the presentation that we gave
the first time we met with this body
um we went through the colors of money
and we went through this presentation at
a very rapid pace so
i thought we'd go back and
talk about
the individual programs
um so before the lunch break i had
explained that you know we are working
on a
multimodal transportation plan
however we spend a lot of time talking
about highway projects because
there's a lot of
flexibility in terms of how we spend our
highway dollars
and of course
the majority of the funding that we
receive is for
highway projects
the transit side of the house is a
little more complicated because we're
receiving federal funds for both
operations
and for capital improvements
and
in many cases we're trying to sustain
our existing services with the funding
that we're receiving there's not as many
opportunities to talk about adding
service or expanding
uh based on the amount of federal
funding that we've received
so in this 10-year plan we have 378
million programmed you know
approximately 37.8 million annually
the primary source of funds is the
federal transit administration
the funds are split into two categories
capital and then operating and planning
um
the funds cannot be transferred for any
other purpose so what we're spending on
transit
can only be used for that purpose
and one of the things that we had noted
previously is the capital corridor rail
project people get confused by this it's
a passenger rail project but it is
funded with transit dollars because
when we did the feasibility study it was
determined that
a commuter service
would
more appropriately meet the needs of the
state than an intercity rail service and
so that's why it's a federal transit
project
because we're looking at a commuter type
frequency
rather than a more intermittent
intercity type frequency that would be
an fra project
so that's sort of how the the funding
works at the macro level
um from the colors of money presentation
you'll recall this number of different
categories so in our world we're always
talking about the 53s 5307 5310
5311. and 53 39 and so
these are all subcategories of federal
funds so we don't just get one big
bucket of federal transit administration
dollars
a lot of the distribution of fta funds
is done in accordance with
census data
and
so we have
urbanized area funds um so that's money
that's going specifically
to services that operate either within
an urbanized area or
to an urbanized area
and so even in that 5307 urbanized
categories we then have subcategories
for example we have the boston urbanized
area
and the boston uca and we use funding
that we receive from the fta to support
the boston express bus service that the
dot
provides with some of that 5307 funding
and then the other recipients of the
5307 categories are
nashua
and the small ucas
so the coast that operates on the
seacoast manchester transit nashua
transit
wildcat the service that's run by the
university of new hampshire and these
are all services that are eligible for
these urbanized area funds
um
in contrast we then have rural programs
that's the 5311 category
and so we receive money by formula um to
service rural areas the majority of that
money is going to the smaller rural
transit providers however we do receive
another category of money which is the
5311 f program
and i apologize this is just the
terminology that fta uses
um
but 5311f is specifically for us to
provide inter-city connections um so
we've done procurements in the past to
identify
bus companies that be willing to provide
service
between cities so we have a service as
an example from littleton down to the
boston area that we fund with some of
our rural intercity funding
and then the
other major category is 5310
so that's the service for
seniors and individuals with
disabilities
and we have in new hampshire
a state coordinating council and then
regional coordinating councils which
help us work with all the non-profits
and local governments to
distribute those dollars and meet the
needs of the
different areas of the state when it
comes to transportation for that
population so those are the three big
categories and then lastly we have the
5339 which is all about
replacing buses
and
upgrading bus facilities so we do
separate solicitations then to
distribute the 53-39
so that sort of gives you the four major
categories so it's urbanized money 5307
rural money 5311.
5310 for seniors individuals with
disabilities and then sort of more
capital type money the 53.39 for buses
and bus facilities
and shelly is truly the expert so when
it comes to the
how we push the money out
you know the different providers in the
different regions she can talk about our
relationship with all of
the different entities
um
the last thing i would just say is we do
have some flexibility we can transfer
highway money to transit we can't take
transit money and move it to highway but
we can move
some categories of highway funds over to
support transit
um so we do have an additional 30
million it's about 3 million per year
that we're transferring from federal
highway to fta for transit
that was something that was supported in
past 10-year plans because we received
so much advocacy for expanding transit
options
and there really is a compelling need to
invest more in transit
that was a determination that was made
in past 10-year plans
and really three million per year when
you consider how much we're receiving in
federal funds
doesn't really hinder our ability
significantly on the highway side to
deliver projects
so i i guess
the services themselves we have 11 local
transit providers that we partner with
there are seven intercity bus routes
that we're supporting
there's two passenger rail services that
currently new hampshire does not
contribute to but there is passenger
rail service in the state with the
downeaster operating
on the seacoast side and the vermonter
servicing claremont
associated with these services we talked
about this briefly at one of the past
meetings we do have a number of transit
terminals
um along the 93 corridor as well as
terminals in portsmouth and dover in
addition to that we have the other park
and ride lots that aren't serviced by
transit but certainly are part of
ensuring that folks have options beyond
driving individually in vehicles
and a big piece of meeting
the needs of our senior population
is our volunteer driver programs to the
197 communities in the state have
volunteer driver programs
and so that's what we can afford to pay
for and that's what we
are supporting today
and this committee has received i
believe some testimony from
some of the transit providers around
their thoughts and concerns
and the biggest issue you'll hear them
talk about is just
coming up with the matching dollars to
access
all of these federal funds
on the operating side it's a 50 50
program so it's 50 federal you have to
bring a 50 match to the table
and then on the capital side it's an 80
20 split like our highway projects are
um
and so the state does provide assistance
when it comes to the matching of capital
dollars but when we're talking about
operating the only assistance that the
state currently provides is two hundred
thousand dollars that was budgeted
through hb1 for that purpose
um and so i know a number of the transit
agencies are concerned this year in
particular with the increase in the
amount of federal funding being made
available through the iija
they now have to come up with the
corresponding match to be able to access
those dollars
so i'll pause there i think that gives
you a pretty good overview
but we can take more specific questions
from the comm any any representative
faulkner
thank you
we've been talking a little bit about
the capital corridor project earlier
today
what funds
federal funds might be used for that is
that one of these programs or is
that come out of 5309
so currently we are advancing what's
called the project development phase of
the capital corridor project
that means we are doing the engineering
to be able to come up with accurate cost
estimates
for both the
capital construction as well as
working with the mbta who has the
operating rights of the corridor to
understand what the true cost of
operating the system would be
we're also
updating the environmental permitting
based on the final design
and what i've been saying repeatedly is
the most important piece of this phase
is developing a financial plan to
explore all of those options as to how
we might pay for construction
and or pay for the operating should the
state decide to progress
so the department
over the years has been a lot of
advocacy for the rail project there's
also been a lot of skepticism around
whether or not we can afford the rail
project so the project development phase
gives us the opportunity to truly vet
um
all of the different options available
to us when it comes to to paying for
this service
and we are looking at a commuter service
so the discretionary grant programs that
would be
possible sources of funding for the
construction
are what's called new starts or small
starts
those are fta administered discretionary
grant programs
we perhaps could pursue
those dollars to construct the project
however we still have to come up with
the match
over the years there has been private
sector as well as municipal support for
the project indications that
there might be a desire to set up
tif districts and and have development
around the stations that might lead to
new sources of revenue
to help pay for either the capital
construction if it was bonded
or to pay for the operating expenses
we do know that if we were to build this
project
we would be eligible for more
fta funding for operations and so we
would have access to some additional
federal funding
and of course we'd charge fares for the
use of the system
but it's unlikely that there would be
sufficient funding purely from farebox
recovery to cover the operating expenses
so this is why we're doing this project
development phase we're going through
all the options
um you know as part of the feasibility
study and also as part of the financial
plan we have looked at how other states
have funded projects but based on
current law in new hampshire some of
those funding mechanisms
would not be permitted
the legislature would have to
be willing to embrace new revenue
streams to pay for rail
um
depending on the different alternatives
there might be different degrees of
support
so
the department is just
tasked with finding options
we're going to develop this financial
plan but the goal of this project phase
was to present the information to the
legislature and other elected leaders so
once and for all we could have a
discussion around whether or not any of
these revenue
sources are acceptable
and if they aren't
how could we afford to pay for the
project with real cost information both
for construction and for operating
so our goal is to provide that
information for the legislature to make
a decision
so we're currently funding this phase
with fta dollars matched with toll
credits
so there's no state funds being used um
at this time
and we are what's in the 10-year plan is
purely this project development phase
if at the conclusion of this phase there
is a desire to move into construction
then we'd have to pursue grants and
program those dollars at that time
so our goal was to get this phase done
so in the next 10-year plan cycle
we could talk about securing the funding
if the desire of the legislature was to
move forward
yes
commissioner when is the uh expected
completion date for all this
for the project development phase
so our goal was to be
wrapping up the financial planning phase
which is really the last piece in
january of 23.
thank you
thank you we're really just starting the
financial planning work now we had to do
enough of the design work to know the
costs better
without the estimates we can't start to
line up available dollars
representative ebal
thank you mr chair
um
when you're with the work that you're
doing for the capitol court or are you
looking at um
costs and how well it could be supported
if it just goes to nashua then if it
just goes to manchester then if it goes
all the way to concord are you breaking
it up that way
based on the
outcomes from the feasibility study what
was deemed to be the most viable was a
commuter
frequency service to manchester so that
is what the project development is for
so not concrete correct
on on federal transit
funding
you mentioned that for the state portion
we use toll credits
are are there not some of these in the
transit arena that also require a local
match or is it all
federal transit and total credits
so we do not use total credits typically
for transit
um we
i think i reference the use of total
credit specifically for the project
development phase of the capital
corridor
as was mentioned
this morning when we were talking about
total credit balances
we are authorized to use toll credits
to match federal funds
for highway projects road and bridge
projects anytime we use total credits
for a purpose beyond that we have to go
to
cboc for their approval
so we have on occasion use turnpike
total credits to match federal funds
for example for the bx the boston
express service
for the capital corridor project
but the majority of the time when we're
funding the transit providers
they are required to secure the match
on the operating side
on the capital side we go through hb 25
and we
secure matching dollars
to support the capital purchases but all
that we have currently budgeted
in general funds is two hundred thousand
to support the operating
um the local transit agencies are coming
up with the match
beyond that to access the operating
dollars
thompson
uh commissioner
is there any
projection on what ridership would be
out of manchester and nashville
which i assume are the only two stations
you'd have
so we have some forecasts around
ridership
shelly is with me today but we could
certainly come back and walk this
committee through
the most recent presentation materials
that we have
shared at public meetings on the capitol
corridor project
as you can imagine
coming out of the pandemic
um
we've seen a lasting shift in commuter
uh patterns there's a lot of companies
are embracing telework on a permanent
basis
and so the mbta has been adjusting their
service and frequency of service to
better match
what they see is the needs of commuters
moving forward so we've been having a
lot of conversations with our colleagues
down in massachusetts
um to make sure that as we discuss the
service
it really is
aligned with what they're providing
today and what they believe they'll be
providing for frequency of service into
the future you have to remember there
are trains already running from lowell
massachusetts to boston
what we're talking about is extending
the service up to manchester
so you're not running dedicated trains
you're running trains that would pick up
passengers in new hampshire and then
continue to pick up passengers
from lowell south
that's why the the cost of operations um
is a little different to calculate
because we're extending existing service
we're not creating a brand new service
so
yeah so we don't i don't have all the
numbers on the capital card or with me
but we can certainly bring that to next
week's work session if that's something
you'd like to spend some time going
through so this is called the capitol
corridor project but it doesn't come to
the capitol
the rail corridor
between concord and boston is known as
the capital corridor so the project that
we are proposing would be to construct
the rail line between lowell
and manchester there is a line there
today
it's just a freight line
really what we're doing is upgrading
that line to meet passenger standards
thank you commissioner thank you
if the transit authorities all however
many
do not come up with
the match of all the new federal money
are we going to leave that money on the
table or how does that how will that
work
yes if you don't have adequate match to
access federal funds you know as we
talked about this morning with the
highway programs you would be at risk of
leaving those federal funds on the table
the one thing i will say is during the
covid pandemic there were several relief
bills that were passed so there was the
cares act
there was another
relief bill chrisa and then there was
the american rescue plan
so
transit did receive a significant amount
of relief funding
um so we have been able to use federal
funds at a hundred percent
if we have relief dollars we can use
those to supplement traditional formula
dollars
and so
that might provide a little bit of a
buffer to the transit agencies because
we're still spending down those balances
of relief funds
and that's why we're you know now that
the care is sorry the
iija has been passed we're working with
the transit agencies to understand
what match gaps they have
but of course this all happened in
december so it's fairly recent that we
started these conversations
if i can just add on relative to whether
the funds would go away the federal
transit administration is a little
different than federal highway
and that when funds are apportioned for
a federal fiscal year depending on the
program we have between three to five
years by which we have to obligate those
funds in a grant we don't have to spend
them in the year they're apportioned we
have a three to five year window in
which we have to just
um obligate them in a grant and by
obligating them in a grant we have to
confirm that we have a a match available
and then we can continue to spend those
funds until expended so we there is a
little bit more liberal use but
if the state has a heavy bounds or a
high balance of the formula funds
when transit systems or the state goes
in for a discretionary grant sometimes
that's held against the state because
there's a backlog of funds that we can't
access already so there's a question as
to why we're seeking additional funds
so there is some ramp up time that's the
positive thing on the transit side
because we have this three to five year
window to spend the money there's time
to work with municipalities and others
to try and increase the amount of match
available but at the end of the day you
still have to find the money
to be able to access the dollars they do
expire eventually
and what we've seen is in
reauthorization bills they sustain or
increase funding they don't reduce it
so it's not as if we could
match at a lower level
carry the balances forward you're always
going to be getting more federal funds
that you need to access
representative jack
thank you mr chairman there were numbers
developed in the alternatives analysis
was completed in 16 or 18 that you
referred to earlier i would refer
representative thompson that the
question is
is the financial plan using those
numbers or have they developed updated
numbers for ridership and economic
activity that they're using
so we're jumping back to the capital
corridor we have updated the ridership
numbers there's some different forecasts
based on different scenarios with
respect to the pandemic and we can
certainly walk the committee through all
of that next week if you'd like us to
plan some time to discuss that topic
thank you
we will see if we have the time
representative ebal
so i'm i'm looking at the cmac
funds
um
how much i mean i feel like there have
been times that we've used the cmaq
funds for other things like park and
rides
i mean you can't use those as a mat i
mean what's the flexibility with their
usage
um so where cmac is concerned we could
use it for transit
if you're providing say a new service
in an effort to reduce congestion by
encouraging people to ride public
transit
however
you still have to find a way to pay for
the operations of that service long term
so if you use cmac to start up a new
transit service
then you have three years
before you have to find a way to make
that service self-sufficient
from an operating perspective
so that's why it's been challenging to
use cmac for transit specifically
but there are many different types of
projects that are eligible under cmaq
from constructing park and rides because
it encourages both carpooling as well as
perhaps could provide access to transit
if we have a terminal at that park and
ride location
to some of the corridor improvements
that we have invested in
walking and biking projects that we've
invested in
anything that's giving people options
other than continuing to drive
just can i follow mr chair
um
does it deal with what i asked her to
come back for as far as transit rail
aeronautics
before we just start jumping around the
book for different subjects
i was just going to ask how it's
determined what we get for cmac funding
what that formula is did you hear me
so cmac is one of the set-aside programs
so it's a federal highway program it's
not a federal transit program
but what happens is we receive a total
apportionment
and then we're required to spend a
certain amount in these sub-allocations
of c-mac
tap which is transportation alternatives
h-sip the highway safety improvement
program
and then we have to use at least 50
percent of what we are
what you calculate by set aside for cmac
you can flex some of it to other more
general purposes but what we have seen
over the years
with programs like tap and see mac is
they can sometimes be oversubscribed so
if we're receiving
more project applications than we have
dollars then it's hard to justify
flexing
that money to another category um cmac
there has to be you do a cost benefit
analysis and you have to show that there
truly is an air quality benefit
from the project so there's been times
when individuals have asked for
you know a sidewalk project
or something of that nature to be cmaq
funded but we can't justify it based on
how they calculate the air quality
improvement
that's why those projects are better
candidates for tap transportation
alternatives but we have had projects
the um
the rail trail project that we're doing
on the seacoast extending the greenway
and that's a project where we did use
cmac funds to acquire the corridor and
are advancing that rail trail because it
could be a commuting corridor
because the number of points of access
based on the forecasted use of that card
or it was eligible for c-neck
representative faulkner thank you
jeremiah uh you mentioned beforehand
that if
we have additional
services we may get additional
money out of the federal programs
could you just maybe explain what what
elements go into the formula both
transit and perhaps even highways things
so each of the different programs the
commissioner explained before the 53s
they all have a slightly different
funding basis on the national level and
some of them are based on population so
different subsets of the population in
those geographic areas and some
are based on revenue miles and passenger
trips so i think the commissioner was
explaining in the case of the new
hampshire capital corridor after so many
years
of
providing that information to the
federal government through the formula
we would then generate additional
dollars based on those additional rail
miles those revenue miles and through
the passenger trips but it would
probably take about three years before
that data went in that we would see that
incremental increase in the funding
programs for that service
any further questions about transit and
the transit project
i they're
broken up within our um
the the
proposed
plan
based on location if i if i remember
correctly going through it
some of them are
just under
area
just so that people can start looking
for it
and the reason i bring that up is all of
a sudden you if you're walking around
the state house you are now the subject
matter experts on the intermodal uh
transportation plan from your colleagues
so at least be able to show them where
where to go
yes if you are looking at your 10-year
plan book and you go to the back of the
book
that's where we have all of the
state-wide programmatics
that's all the
the programs we don't have an individual
project location so for example on page
2 212 and 213 you'll see the funding for
manchester transit
and nashua transit
and so it's all accounted for in the
10-year plan
whether it's their operating assistance
for their fixed route service
or what they're
providing for service to seniors
individuals with disabilities we have it
all called out separately so you'll see
the same transit agency appear multiple
times because it'll be their use of 5307
or
5311 depending on whether they're urban
or rural as well as their allocation of
as well as any capital projects that we
anticipate being funded
it is by
to your point it is by geographic so the
systems that are in the large urbanized
areas who have to put their grants in
directly to the federal transit
administration are specifically called
out like the commissioner showed with
manchester and nashua but the 5311 the
rural transit operators are like concord
area transit advanced transit those are
all in one statewide programmatic that
would be fta section 5311 because the
department is the one who administers
the grant funds and therefore we make
the funding decisions so those go in as
a single programmatic
any further questions about transit
funding transit projects within the
proposed plan
see
none of course you do
i just i mean
what i i'm looking at the c-max section
when you have a category that's called
mandated federal what what does that
mean
so as i said before these are required
programs so we get our total
apportionment and then we have these
mandated programs that we have to set
aside funding for like tap c-mac and
h-zip
we do have flexibility that some of the
so you calculate how much by formula you
should be allocating to those programs
and you then have some discretion
to move up to 50 percent of the funding
out of that category into something else
but you're mandated to spend at least 50
percent of what you calculated at cmac
on cmac you're mandated to spend at
least 50
of transportation alternatives on
projects of that type
so across all of the different
subcategories of federal funds
we've talked a lot about the federal
highway program
but it's not just cmak and tap and hcip
we have
stp
nhpp there's all these different
subcategories
and um
you know we have bridge funds off system
bridge funds we're balancing all the
time our allocations in each of those
subcategories it's not just one giant
bucket of federal funds
thank you
the sections
just if we could go over
rail funding
and the fact that
what
does this money pay for and where it
comes from i know we went over it
briefly at one of our prior meetings on
the source of funding but what does it
benefit
what type of
state-owned rails
does it benefit
within the 10-year plan we only have
10.6 million programmed for
rail
and that's about 1.1 million per year
that is general funds
so we're prohibited from using highway
funds for anything other than a highway
purpose
so when we're funding aeronautics rail
and transit beyond federal dollars it's
always general funds that we're
accessing
we have what's called the special
railroad fund so approximately 600 000
per year flows into the special railroad
fund that's primarily coming from the
lease agreements that we have with
private rail operators who use the
state-owned corridors
the funds that we raise
through those operating agreements go
right back into the rail corridor so
we're using those funds for maintenance
and construction on the state-owned
lines
so that's why it's beneficial you know
we release the lines to the operators
and then we take a piece of the revenue
to keep those lines in a good state of
repair
in addition we have the
railroad revolving loan fund um so
we wait till the balances build up and
it ends up being about 1.5 million
that's available every three years or so
um that's a state bonded program
for capital work on their class 3 and
cog railroads so those operators can
come to us and ask to borrow money from
the revolving loan fund
so that's another way that we can pay
for projects in the state
at the end of the day um we have six
railroad operators under service
agreements to work on or to operate on
the state-owned lines four of them are
freight service and then we have our two
tourist and excursion services
we have in total about 153 miles of
active track that is part of these
operating agreements
and then about 41 miles of track that's
really used less frequently
and then beyond the active corridors we
have 339 miles of abandoned track
or sorry abandoned corridor
um
and a lot of that is included in
managed rail trail agreements
so
our
rail programs are much smaller than our
other transportation programs
and we are very
dependent on general funds to support
those programs although we do through hb
25 also try to secure dollars to invest
in the rail corridors when it's deemed
necessary
in past budgets we've received some
funding to do work on bridges or
culverts
and then some of the private railroads
have also
come before
the legislature during the development
of hb 25 and requested
funding to supplement what they're
investing in their corridors
because we do have a lot of privately
owned rail corridors in the state
that are important to the shippers that
move their goods on those rail lines
but i think
the point that this committee needs to
make when anybody asks about rail
funding in this
that there is no funding other than
for for passenger rail at this time it
is for freight rail
and the the two uh
tourists and ex excursions services that
we are working with um because that
question will come up why is there
railroad money in the 10-year plan it is
not for
passenger rail it is for state owned
rail corridors that we work with the
people who lease the corridor so that
they can use it
did i say that right commissioner
you did mr chairman and um
yeah the
important thing to remember about the
capital corridor project yes it's a rail
line it's a rail project but it's not
a project where we're using federal
railroad administration grants it's not
funded with the rail dollars that are in
the 10-year plan it's it's a transit
funded project because we're looking at
commuter frequency
so it's actually in the transit side not
the rail side
thank you um any other questions
or comments about rail
freight rail and and what's in
the plan and
see none um
aeronautics
so aeronautics uh
is a little different from these other
programs again because
aeronautics is not part of surface
transportation
so uh when they passed the iija
it was both a surface transportation
reauthorization
bill and an infrastructure bill so in
the iija we're receiving yes more money
for airports in the state
but those dollars are truly above and
beyond what's currently authorized in
law for aeronautics and we've got one
more year left on the appropriations for
or the authorization for aeronautics um
so what's in this 10-year plan we have
382 million programs so it works out to
about 38.2 million per year the primary
source of funds is the federal aviation
administration faa
like the transit side of the house these
are all grant-based programs so while we
anticipate a certain amount of money by
formula
every individual project has to be
submitted to fta in these different
grant categories and receive their
concurrence so that we can advance the
project
and so that's why we refer to it as
discretionary entitlement and state
apportioned
we've got these funding in different
buckets that we're constantly managing
as we submit projects to faa for their
consideration
what we receive by formula is based on
faa's designation of
the priorities nationally to support
aviation
and the most important thing to know is
that not every airport in the state is
eligible for the federal funds
and these funds are restricted purely to
aviation we cannot move them to any
other category
most of the funding programs that are
administered by the faa are
90 10 programs so it's 90 federal with a
10 match and here in new hampshire
we provide 5
state match with 5
coming from the municipalities to make
up that 10 percent
and so we only have 14 projects in this
10-year plan called out by town
an airport name
and that's based on the projects that we
know have been approved by faa
the rest of the money is anticipated
funding
that we have like the fta money
programmed in these programmatic
categories
and then we work with every airport to
develop airport improvement plans
through that process they identify their
projects and then they submit those
projects to faa and as they're funded
we support the airports and moving them
forward
so we have three commercial airports in
the state that's portsmouth manchester
and lebanon
um those commercial airports receive
direct funding
as well as partnering with us to be able
to access
some of the different grant programs
and then we have only nine publicly
owned
airports that are eligible for federal
funds
um and i believe
yes there's a giant poster on the wall
that might be the easiest way for you to
um
look up one of the airports and the
materials that we've passed out you have
the maps to reference but i think that
larger scale one is probably the easiest
for you to reference
in addition to the fed aid eligible
airports we have 12 what we call general
aviation airports they're open to the
public and privately owned and because
they're privately owned they're not
eligible for federal funds
but they are an important part of the
overall
network in new hampshire
um so the like i said there's a lot less
discussion of
uh the airport projects just because of
the nature of the programs and how
they're administered
and we're not sitting with this
committee trying to identify where you'd
like to spend the money
in the way that we are in the highway
side
and certainly if there's very detailed
questions i can have trish lambert
attend next week's work session but i
can do my best to answer any questions
that you might have today
any questions about aeronautics
is there a need to have
the department to come back and talk
about it next week
okay thank you
the one thing i would be remiss if i
didn't point out
so like
public transportation
there was a lot of relief funding made
available for airports as you can
imagine you know day one of the pandemic
especially our commercial airports they
were significantly impacted
by
covet 19. and so once again
just like transit you know the cares act
chrisa arp
through those different relief bills new
hampshire did receive a significant
amount of funding
i think in total it's about 36 million
that we received in covert relief for
aeronautics purposes
some of those funds went directly to the
airports like at the three commercial
airports they receive operating
assistance directly
and we helped disperse the funding to
the other nine fed eight eligible
airports
um unlike transit we were able to take
that 10 match and convert it to federal
so if we had existing projects that were
you know grants that were already funded
we could
remove the state and local match and add
some of the federal relief funds to make
them a hundred percent
um so that's certainly been um
beneficial to the airports as they've
tried to navigate the pandemic period
thank you
there are
quite a few mandated federal programs as
you get especially towards the back of
the book i would just ask the committee
to look at them some of them will
surprise you
that
that big bucket of money starts getting
smaller as you start taking out some of
those mandated programs
not saying that they're good bad or
indifferent it's just it's been mandated
that we spend them in a certain way
but i'll go back to
one of the things that
representative evil brought up cmac i
know that there is a process for
determining how that is
however in the 10-year plan all we have
is
year and how much is going to be spent
on certain
um
things on the programmatic page 199
preliminary engineering but it doesn't
say where
right away et cetera et cetera
so this is funding that has not yet been
assigned to cmac projects
so what we have done over the last 10
year plan cycles is to alternate between
a c-max solicitation and a tap
solicitation
so this time around it was a tap a
transportation alternatives program
solicitation
so we had
released that notice received project
candidates from municipalities scored
those projects
and then worked with gasset to
incorporate
the ones that we could fund and
recommended supporting into the draft
10-year plan
so this time around we were doing tap
next 10 year plan cycle we will do a
round of cmak so if you look through the
book you will find cmaq funded projects
those are ones that
we've done a prior solicitation and
selected
in a previous 10-year plan round
what you're seeing here is the balance
of the c-mac program
what's really challenging about the
federal highway programs is we receive
an annual apportionment
and we actually have three years to
spend
that category of money
what's different from the transit
programs and the aeronautics programs is
we still have to obligate a total amount
each year
so this is one of the most complicated
things to describe to communities
because they see their cmaq project as
an example in the 10-year plan they
think that money is secure
and then something happens they don't
deliver it on time
and because we're capped in how much we
can spend each annual year
and the fact that the allocations also
expire on a three-year cycle sometimes
we might lose that color of money if
they don't advance their project quickly
enough
so that's what we're constantly working
to resolve with communities
um
so as an example under the fast act our
annual apportionment what we received by
formula in total was about
185 million a little shy of that
but our annual amount that we could
actually obligate was only 160 something
million
the reason being is you always want to
have more projects going forward then
you have dollars available because
inevitable with the permitting process
you know and design progression
public input
some things might slip but we always
have three years to spend that category
of money so usually you can manage it
year to year and what's challenging is
if something goes wrong with a project
and people don't get it over the finish
line within that three year window you
might lose that color of money
usually we're getting enough
additional apportionment in each of
these subcategories that we can free up
money of that type but it's
it's very um challenging for us
to
balance all of this and you lapse money
in these categories
which does not mean we give federal
funding back
we might have consciously decided not to
spend a certain color of money but i can
guarantee you we obligate every penny
that we have available to us every year
what we might let lapse is a color of
money because we chose not to do that
type of project we chose to do something
else so it's the difference between
authorization apportionment
contract authority and obligation it's
and it's one of the hardest things for
us to communicate to the rpcs and to the
municipalities
but the bottom line what we try to do is
keep it simple we gave you money we gave
it to you in a certain year please try
to advance your project within this time
frame and then there's no risk you'll
get your project done
any
further questions of the commissioner
she's been here a couple of hours now
with us
that burning questions you'd like to
have answered today
she will be available with us next week
if
looking ahead for next week
if you have something specific that you
would like the commission
commissioner or or anyone in the
department to answer
about projects funding where we go from
here
please
let me know and i will get it to
probably kathy's the best or to you
commissioner
kathy's actually on vacation um until
early february so you can just send it
to me directly um
we have several people out for various
reasons so that's why you're
going to spend so much quality time with
me personally
oh you don't like us that much
i'm always happy to be here
but any questions right
representative edgar
thank you mr chairman
i'd like to at least bring up the topic
not for discussion right now necessarily
but for at least next week that has to
do with any resiliency funds
maybe i can find out what what that
means
uh by that i mean is what private
programs if any there is if there's
additional funds for that on any
programs and how it's being decided and
where they would be like i said not
necessarily to discuss now but if we
could discuss it next week i'd
appreciate it
thank you just briefly um in the iija
there was new
mandatory programs established so
in your
presentations from the previous sessions
you know we talk a lot about these other
programs like i said there's alphabet
soup stp nhpp
believe it or not there's additional
ones that were funded in the iija some
of them relate to resiliency and climate
change so one of the new ones is the
protect program
protect
actually we have dollars coming by
formula but then protect also has a
discretionary component where you could
apply for grants so we have a lot of
culvert work um slope stabilization work
and other types of projects that we were
already trying to use are flexible
categories of federal funding for
we're hoping to either do more of that
work or fund those projects with protect
so i can have
pete stamnis and glenn davison pulled
together some examples of where we would
hope to spend those dollars for next
week
very good thank you because we're
probably going to get flooded out again
this weekend down in hampton so it could
be a nice topic next week thank you
well ocean boulevard is a probably a
perfect candidate to apply for
discretionary grants um once we have
done some of the initial design work um
so there's certainly projects we could
talk about that would be ideal
candidates
thank you
representative newman
commissioner on page
um
portsmouth
it's a the sound wall along i-95 in
we've chatted quite a bit about sound
walls
um i see a total project cost of 10 mil
10 million 500 000. how how large of a
i guess what is the distance of that
sound wall
so i'll be happy to bring the map that
shows the locations that qualified for a
sound wall
um
so that project is associated with the
shoulder running project that i
discussed this morning so what happened
in the gasset phase was we had planned
to advance the shoulder running project
and then subsequently
build the sound walls with turnpike
funds based on the advocacy that we
heard
during the 10-year plan hearings
working with them counseling stevens we
moved up the sound wall project we
switched the funding to federal funds
and so now both projects are being
advanced in parallel then i can bring
you the map so you can see which
segments of sound wall are being
constructed
thank you
what was that after
um
you mentioned the delay in the concord
um the stretch out here on 93 in concord
is there any opportunity there to do
shoulder running for the exiting traffic
because it's always right at
rush hour that we also get the influx
from out of state headed north
so when we have
races at the
new hampshire motor speedway at loudoun
we do use the shoulder
however
one of the challenges and the reason
that we
need to advance the bill concord project
is the spacing of the exits
and how short some of those ramps and
merges are
so actually when we do shoulder running
to support race traffic we close some of
the on-ramps because there wouldn't be
adequate
acceleration space for traffic that was
trying to merge into the corridor so
that's what really has hindered us from
looking at a shoulder running option
because of the safety concerns
the way that those
exits or interchanges are spaced it's
not as
conducive to that
unlike the 95 scenario where we're
looking at a bridge we're just going to
do the shoulder running for a location
section where the merges wouldn't be as
much of a concern
thank you very much
any other
questions for today
representative clutier
okay thank you uh again and it's more
for you mr chairman so if we have any
questions about specific projects should
we reach out to the commission in
advance of next week i just want to be
clear about that or who should we
contact you can reach out to me directly
or reach out through
the chair and
compile a list but um okay we'll do our
best to be ready with whatever questions
you have okay
the only thing i would ask if the
members reach out directly to the
commissioner they put me as a courtesy
copy on the email so at least i know
what's coming
represent faulkner
can i just express my appreciation for
commissioner i'm impressed with your
knowledge of the details and your
willingness to share all them with us
and
i think we're lucky to have
this level of support appreciate it
thank you for that
uh thank you and
he stole my thunder but thank you
thank you commissioner uh it is
important that we get
as much information as we can not just
about the the federal highway piece but
our entire intermodal
transportation because it's going to
become
in my opinion even more important as
we try to revitalize some some freight
rail and and other things within the
state to take
some of the traffic off of the highways
because we're not going to keep
adding lanes to the turnpikes or the
interstates so
we need to be looking at at how this
entire process fits together
so thank you
before we conclude mr chairman i just
want to
touch on the action items from the
department so i mentioned this morning
that we're updating our projections for
toll credits
to reflect the federal bill as well as
the timing of all the turnpike work
i also committed to reaching out to the
representatives for hudson to talk about
hudson boulevard
and what their specific request might be
and then based on the conversation this
afternoon we were going to get the
ridership projections for the capital
corridor project
that's what i have is our three actions
i don't know if there's anything that we
missed
oh keen letter
that i was going to send that separately
not wait for the work session um yes i
have a the keen
item and then i also have an item to
follow up with representative eaton on
so i have some sidebar things to do and
the piece on the resiliency
funding if if any
i will send before the hearing the sound
wall map also
represent thompson
uh commissioner on the
we discussed the other day about um
the 17 million for the eb charging
infrastructure
um
and at the time you said you
were still waiting for details from the
federal government is that still true or
that's something that's really important
i think particularly for our committee
but
others as well because there's a number
of bills pending
that need to know
that information
really before those bills proceed
in my opinion
um so with respect to the ev charging
there's been no guidance released yet by
usdot
there was a guidance document about
ensuring that if you are going to have
a fee associated with using a charging
station
that it be
solely to cover the costs of operating
that charging station and not a revenue
generating opportunity
um that's the only piece of information
that we've received recently and so you
can
charge a fee for charging
um
infrastructure but it has to discover
the cost of the maintenance
and we're still there was a
request for information issued by
usdot that different entities have been
responding to so i assume that on the
conclusion of that comment period
they will digest all of that and then
turn it into a guidance document
what we did in the ten year plan as we
touched on previously was we've just
programmed the dollars they are dollars
that cannot be used for any purpose
other than this
um so we're receiving the 17.5 million
by formula
and then there is a discretionary grant
program in addition that new hampshire
could apply for should we want to pursue
additional funding for charging
infrastructure
the transportation council that was
established by the legislature
their charge is to work with the
department and help inform
deployment of new and emerging
technologies
so they believe they have a role to play
when it comes to ev charging
infrastructure
we have
we know that to be able to access these
federal dollars we have to develop a
plan as to where we would install the
units and over what time period
so
it has been suggested
that perhaps we would consult with the
transportation council it's a diverse
group
that perhaps could help us
with that process but of course as i had
mentioned in one of our earlier sessions
we aren't
in this alone while the funding would
flow through usdot to the department of
transportation we've been working really
closely first with the office of
strategic initiatives which has now of
course
been replaced by
the department of energy
but also with the department of
environmental services
so we plan to collaborate with them
irrespective of what paths the
legislature
decides to pursue i know senator waters
has
two bills i believe this session that
are
working their way through the process
one is to establish the
electric uh vehicle infrastructure
fund
which is where these federal dollars
might flow into
um and then a separate bill talking
about
um conversion
of the fleet um for projects like uh
replacement of school buses as an
example and that being something that
would be administered by the department
of environmental services
so we need to learn more about the
programs
and what role then the state agencies
will play to administer those programs
but for the moment we know the money is
flowing through usdot to dot so we have
it just accounted for in the 10-year
plan
thank you
i'm going to go back to how you started
that explanation
you said part of the initial guidance
that you are aware of says that
if you set up the the charging station
all you can do is collect for the the
cost of the the station and the
electricity
so that if somebody from another state
came in and charged it would just be the
minimal cost of the electricity whereas
if they bought gas we'd at least get
some money for our roads
is that kind of
correct
on what you understand now from the
rules
that is my understanding but like i said
there's been this comment period um and
there's
there's concerns if we're using federal
funds we have to comply with buy america
um there's a lack of
buy america compliant equipment being
produced right now
so some of this is to spur industry
to ramp up production to meet the needs
because of course we want to buy
american products but there has to be
one on the market otherwise these
dollars will go unspent um so there's
you know numerous aspects of the rollout
of these new programs that
federal highway wants to hear from all
the stakeholders so they can address
those in their guidance
thank you
representative newman
thank you commissioner
you mentioned next week you'll have some
information on
i think you said projections or at least
rough ideas of
potential
ridership on
commuter rail
and we can
either ahead of next week's work session
or during the work session share some of
the presentation materials that we've
been using at the public meetings
associated with the capitol corridor
okay could i follow up mr chairman yes
commissioner um will will that also
include some of the
i guess how the research was obtained
in other words
people will be going from north to south
there will be ridership
from south to north like boston north
and and southern new hampshire south
um it is
so there'll be some indication on how
the research was up or how your
information was obtained we have
forecasts for the number of riders from
each station
down to boston
as we're doing this analysis there's
standard fta models that you use to
project ridership
so
all the methodology that goes into that
modeling um if the committee wants to
see some of that documentation we can
certainly share it but we'll we can give
you the what we used as the tool to
project the ridership
follow-up
but don't inand date the commun this
enough you uh to the commissioner don't
inundate the the committee with
um
the entire model and how it all all the
algorithms work please
as i've i can reference the model that
we're using but yes i wasn't intending
to go through all the details yeah i
agree i mean it too much is too much
how
will the uh i would just ask
for um i guess just for discussion
purposes when we see the information
is it
um was it um i don't know how to put
this together in other words we've got
information that was there
pre-pandemic and now we're in pandemic
and looking to go post-pandemic so is
there a
some kind of a
she's shaking her head apparently so
okay thank you yeah we used a few
different models that showed pandemic
impact so a slight impact
a medium impact and a heavier impact so
yeah we've been taking that into account
and we're working with the federal
transit administration we're using
a model that they approve of for
projecting ridership and we're going
back and forth with them on a much more
detailed to the chairs point that you
probably don't want to look at document
that
behind the scenes codifies all that but
yeah so we have some projections
basically for projections
in what we provided to the public and we
could share with you
thank you
and for the committee's edification we
will briefly talk about the ongoing
study and planning
understanding that it's over a year away
about a year away before it'll be
finalized
we can get some information but it's not
going to impact on what we have to do
with the current 10-year plan
for those of us or you who may be back
here
two years from now it may be more
pertinent to have that study in front of
you
but it will be finished in 23 after the
next general election
anything else from the committee for
the commissioner at this point
if not thank you again very much uh
commissioner
we do appreciate
all the support that the department
gives us
um both
with the rpc's the gasset and then with
us
as it works through
the house and then the senate
so you can start the whole process again
this summer
true dad
um thank you all for seeing those who
did um
i will see you all next week
but please
the two things if you have something you
need the
department to clarify get it in early
so we're not playing let me go see if
somebody's in the office to get the
answer
and two if you think you want to have a
change made
to the 10-year plan work with lls about
having a an amendment drawn up we will
look at all of them
and then work on a
consolidated amendment that we may be
able to agree to and commissioner
whatever language you need
for
inclusion
um i would appreciate that too there's
always something that that the
department needs
um as you referenced earlier there's the
standard sections that we have to add
into the 10-year plan bill so i just
want to be clear on timeline do you want
us to bring all of that draft language
for next week's work session or be
thinking about it and work online if you
could bring it the next one in draft
because then we'll try to
work on a consolidated one for two weeks
later for an executive session
so that we can finalize this and get it
to the senate
because time is fleeting
that's fine and we'll just bring the
suggested language and we can convert it
into an actual amendment at a later date
perfect
again thank you we'll see you all next
week
you